right in this full ui5 course
uh you will learn everything you need to
know to get started with
ui5 um this course is perfect for
beginners
who have a little bit of javascript
experience
it's great for app guys who want to
learn more about the front-end side of
things
and it's also great as a general
refresher for your ui5 skills
the course itself will come will
eventually wind up with you
having a app that looks similar to this
and it follows each individual step
of the sap ui5 walkthrough
from step one all the way through to
step 38
some will go into more details uh some
will
go through but in a more general way um
and we'll leave that for sort of a
a separate video on each topic so for
example
unit testing we go through briefly but
not in a huge amount of detail
same thing with accessibility because
those sections require
their own sort of course but for the
most part we go through
all of the basics um and
the walkthrough itself is something i've
been through over a dozen times
i jump around and and look at various
things just to refresh my mind
and i find it incredibly helpful which
was the reason for the course
so obviously going through the video you
can jump around
pretty much as much as you want and you
can always
use this as a reference when you're
actually building parts of the
application
each step in the video is handled by
a commit in this ui 5 repository on my
github
so you can come here and if you
want to start from any particular step
you can browse the files
and you can just simply download the
code or open it up in github and
continue from there so
you're more than welcome to jump around
as you go
using the commits as a guide for
whatever step
you happen to be on
so i'm going to be running all of these
well this example from my local machine
using visual studio code so your code
will eventually look like this
and i'm running this on my local machine
so alongside this i'll be using the ui5
cli so we'll be doing things like ui5
serve which will help us
actually serve the app locally
and the reason we're using uh uf the ui5
cli and
node is uh because you will eventually
run into
a cause issue if you try and do this uh
sort of com you know on your local
machine as it is um
and you will eventually run into this
issue and
unfortunately being a vulnerability it
just it'll be quite hard for you to do a
workaround
you can work in the sap web ide and
configure things like destinations for
your remote odata services
and get around this that's up to you but
if you want to follow this course from
start to finish
we're going to use your ide of choice
like eclipse or visual studio code
the ui5 cli and obviously node to run
the server
so again the cause issue will be linked
in the description below so have a look
for that because
it's tripped up many developers
including myself
and at one at i think it's step 26 or 27
we will create a remote odata service
for the first time using northwind
this again because of the cause issue um
won't work
there are workarounds that will be
available to you if you want to
continue that way but otherwise we will
continue
from that step using a mock server which
is
in any case an sap based practice so
look out for that as we go that'll be a
change there
and yeah um i hope it winds up helping
you guys
um and yeah let's jump
let's jump right in
so now in the prerequisites section
we're going to get our local machine
ready to run
any code we write using node so
we're effectively setting up a node
server with the
ui5 tooling as well um
if you're using sap web ide you could
skip the step
um but if you're working on your local
machine which i'm sure most of you are
i'm going to follow along through all
the different steps so you know exactly
what i did to get going so
the first thing oh this is also going to
overlap with
section one or step one a little bit
which is fine because
obviously things have changed since they
created the walkthrough
and we're going to run it in the more
sort of
modern way i guess so um
first step is going to be creating a new
folder so we're inside our project
folder whatever you've called it
and now we're going to create an app
folder which
by naming convention we're going to call
web app
we're going to leave this here for now
and the next thing is we're going to
start with
the ui5 cli and make sure that's
installed it's already installed for me
but i'm going to run through it with you
and then
we'll go from there so you run
npm install
globally at ui5
cli let that run
brilliant and to verify the installation
we can run this command
which is a ui5
help and if it is successful you'll see
all your different ui5 commands here
that you can use so that's obviously
successful for us
now we need to enable an existing
project
so we've already got our project folder
and we've got a web app folder in here
as well so we are going to
enable it to work with the um the node
server
so um the first thing we need to do is
create our package.json file
and to do that which would be the same
in any other node project
you type npm in it yes
and that'll just create the package file
with everything we need
um so all the details are set there then
we need to generate
a uh ur5.yaml file
and that is ui5 in it
and there we go so now we have a
package.json file
um and and obviously the ui5.yamf yaml
file
briefly this package.json file
just holds metadata related to the
project
this file is used to give information to
node or npm
and allows it to identify the project as
well as handle
the project's dependencies the ur5.yaml
file on the other hand
um is the project's ui5
tooling kind of configuration file i
guess
um so that's that's a sort of in a
nutshell what they do and what they're
there for
[Music]
so now that we've done that we need to
install the dependencies
but before we do that so
for example if you just went ahead and
typed so uh
we're going to use the sap ui 5
dependencies because we will work with
sp ui5
so we're going to pick up an error now
when we try this
so ui5 use sap ui5
and depending on the version you can
obviously choose that version
here we're going to use the latest
version just because
most of the stuff we develop on our as
in
an scp or sap cloud platform so that
always runs on the latest
latest ui5 version when we eventually do
deploy
so you'll see it says error message
failed to read manifest.json file
creating the manifest is also a
step further on down the process we're
going to be doing that a little bit
earlier just so that we can set up
our cli and our node server to run
our project so you will see this come up
in one of the sections obviously coming
up
so for now we're going to go ahead and
go into our web app folder and create
that manifest.json file
there'll be a lot of data in there that
won't make sense if you're fairly new to
this
don't worry we will cover it in a future
section but
we just need it there for now to get our
local project running
so we're going to create a new file call
it
manifest.json and
this will be linked down in the
description
i'm just pulling the data directly from
the sap documentation and you can see
there's a lot
of stuff here that we're going to go
through
but for now we're just going to pull it
all
and add it in here then we just need to
make
a few changes um
so we'll just hide the folder structure
for now so
um if we just scroll through you'll see
we have a
few issues here and there
so the first one is handle validation
we're going to leave that as false for
now because
that's not part of the scope of this
section but we will get to it content
densities
and run everything as false because we
just want a
standard layout again we'll get to all
of this as we
move down the line oh and we just need
to add a comma there
right so we've got no issues here we
should be able to save
and that looks good so we can close that
so now that we have everything all set
up
we're gonna go ahead and follow on step
one
where we're just going to create a hello
world or hello ui5
html file that we're going to display
in the browser here so we're now going
to go
into the web app folder and we're going
to create a new file
called index.html
and i'm just going to copy across the
html
code here because the it's pretty
straightforward
it's very standard html you've got your
head section
a title your body a div
with hello world or we could just say
hello ui5
um and all that's going to happen is
this text is going to be displayed
so if we go ahead and save let's just
close all of this
now that we've gone ahead and saved that
we to
now run this or start running and
testing things
we just simply use the ui5 cli
and type ui5 serve
and that should run it on
this um localhost address here
so we can go ahead and
follow that link
and if we type in slash
index.html
there you are
so the next section we are moving on to
is
bootstrapping and what that means
is when you run a sap ui5 application
you need to load and initialize things
and
when you initialize sap ui5 resources
it's
called bootstrapping and once the
bootstrapping is finished
in our app we are going to tell it to
load a simple javascript alert
so we're going to run a script in the
index.html file
and we're going to pull that we're just
going to copy it directly
from the documentation and so you've got
your id
which is pretty straightforward your
source so this is going to pull it
um from a content delivery network or
cdn network
online uh wouldn't recommend doing that
um if you're running a production app
you should obviously have your resources
or your your the source of your um
sap ui5 libraries and things
set so that it doesn't change which
obviously it would change here
but for now for demo purposes we can
call it from this
cdn url here ui5 has different themes
which you'll see shortly we're just
going to choose
the belize theme the libraries
this is just the probably one of the
more standard ones one of many but it's
sap.m so it's one of the libraries the
compatibility version
must be set to edge or sort of the
latest um
that's what that means uh we need things
to run asynchronously so we set that to
true the difference between synchronous
and asynchronous you can look up online
yourself but effectively asynchronous
means we can run
our when our resources load they don't
wait for each other to load so it
doesn't load one then the other than the
other
they all just sort of load as they would
load if that makes sense um so that's
what asynchronous means
then we have to set our
on init module so um
if you sort of follow this folder
structure
this folder structure is determined or
is sort of masked here
in the resource roots and it's telling
it that
um just for this sort of demo purpose
but more or less to understand
how the folder structure actually works
it's setting it
to this home folder which is
here web app now in doing that
it's saying sap ui demo walkthrough
which is put here so it comes to your
web app section
look at the index
file now we're going to create an
index.js file because
we shouldn't really be running any
javascript
in the html file itself
so that leads us on to
the next point where we're going to go
ahead
and create in our web app folder and
index.js file
so let's go ahead and do that
now in this index.js file
we are going to um
put all the application logic we're
going to use
so um again that's to avoid any
uh executable javascript code in the
html file
so to do that we call sap dot
ui dot def oops
we call sap dot ui dot define
and we open and we open
that up like that
now once we've got that
we need to go ahead and create
a function
and in that function we're not passing
anything yet
we open up our function call and we call
use strict which we'll explain
in a in the sections further on but yeah
don't worry about that for
now
then once we've got our samples you are
defined section
here we're going to call a function
and inside that standard javascript
function
we're going to call our alert so
oops alert
and we're going to say ui5 is
ready to go
and we're going to put our braces there
and we're going to go ahead and save so
we've got our index.html file with our
script ready to go
we've got all we've got the um we're
telling it
where to find the index.js file
which is here and this has been
mapped like that using resource roots
in our index.js file we're calling a
function
and in that function we're just simply
going to call a
an alert so this isn't even a ui5
control it's just a standard javascript
a vanilla javascript alert so now if we
save that
we should be able to refresh
know what's gone wrong
let's try control f5
there we are so um if for whatever
reason uh
it doesn't load when you refresh it
might need a hard refresh so
control f5 i think does that are windows
i don't know what
um i think it's command f5 on a mac but
here you go here is your
you can refresh it again so the hello
ui5
which is here is still here but then
in our index.js file we start to build
a control or a vanilla javascript
alert which is what we've done so if we
refresh
as it runs in the background and loads
you get your reload
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to replace
this text with an actual sap ui5
specific control and we're going to do
that over here
where we'll actually add the control
and pass it in and we're going to remove
this
and we're going to actually assign the
body an id
and add the control here
to that particular id
so what we're going to do
first is remove this
then we're going to come to our
index.html file
and we're going to remove that and in
our body tag
we're going to call a class
called sap ui
body which will just give us a bit of
sap specific formatting
um for this particular body section then
it the important thing now is to add an
id and we'll call this
content
and so now that we've given this an id
we're going to go and save it
and we're going to go and
first off
we need to pull in our
our text control and to do that we need
to use the sap namespace so it's
sap slash m text
and now that we have that here we need
to pass it into our constructor here
for this javascript object so
we just add the text part so we just add
the input
and then once we're in here all we need
to do
is create a new object so new
text
and within that object or within the the
text control rather
we'll have a whole bunch of attributes
and so in this case we're just going to
call the text attribute
and that text will be what is displayed
and we'll call it
hello ui5
whoops now we've got this
this text control here we need to call
the place at
method to place it at
content
and that content is going to be in the
html file
here and so we should see this
still appear when we refresh so i'm
going to go ahead and
save that and just double check this
that's all fine so if we press ctrl
f5
let it load
ah
so if this happens you just need to
rerun
your um your server if if something like
this happens so
again we just call ui5 serve
and there we go we're running again so
we can go ahead and
refresh and there you go and you can see
the formatting
has changed slightly
the font and things has changed a little
bit so
we now have that text here but we're
pulling it through
and sap specific text control from the
sap
m library and we've created that new
control in our index.js file
and we've placed it at content
which is the id of this body tag
so now what we're going to do is we are
going to create
a separate standalone view
to place our text control in
and sap supports
quite a wide range of views and
you can write them in xml html and
javascript
but they recommend xml because um
it produces more readable code and
it also force you it also forces you to
separate your
view declaration from the actual
controller logic
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a separate view folder
a separate view file and then we're
going to
create the view here and we're going to
call it
in the index.js file
so underneath web app we're going to
create a new folder called
view then we're going to physically
create our xml view
and we're just going to call it
app.view.xml
then we're going to open up our tag here
and let's just close it while we're here
um so now what we want to do is we need
to bring in
um the text control and also the
m the sap mvc assets as well which is
fairly standard and i won't go to too
much detail on that
but effectively what you would do is you
would
call xml
and we want the sap.m
library so we're going to pull that in
because that's where our text
controllers
is from
and then we're going to call xmlns again
with an alias of mvc and aliases will
come into play further on
down the line and this is going to be
sap.edu is a dot core
dot mvc so
now that we've got this library
available to us
we can go ahead and add our text control
and declare it so
all we have to do is call text
and call the attribute that we call
before text
and that's going to equal hello
ui5 again for example
and we close that and
that's our control declared as simple as
that
so we can go ahead and save that now
we need to move on to the index.js file
and we're going to ch it's going to
change somewhat
because we're not pulling the text
control directly in here but rather the
view
we need to call the sap
slash ui core
slash mvc
slash xml
view and then we need to change
um the importing
parameter here to xml view
to pull it into our constructor here
now what we're going to do is get rid of
this
text control and we're going to call xml
view dot create
and open up our tags here and then
we're going to assign it the view that
we
are dealing with so we call view name
and that's going to be sap dot
ui dot demo dot walkthrough
dot view dot app
sorry dot um
dot app no almost
and you remember before how when we
reference this
it references the web app folder from
the index.html file here
remember that so that's why that's how
we can call or that's how the folder
structure works
um then we go into our
view folder and then finally we call
the app view which is um
sitting over here
and that's it so once we call that
we then come back on our promise
javascript promise
and we say then once we have that
we call a function and
we're going to call our or pass in our
view so we'll just call it
overview oops
and then open up our function and
you guessed it overview dot place
at content to place it at
content and it
is as easy as that
we'll go ahead and save that and now it
should do exactly the same thing
except it should place our brand new
separated or modularized
text control inside our separate view
over here so just make sure everything's
saved
and if we go here and press ctrl f5
no something's gone wrong
[Music]
what's happened here ah so
um because we're passing it in
this needs to be in quotations my
apologies
that's very important so now if we go
ahead and save
and ctrl f5
ah there's the issue
it's place at it was missing an e there
so if we go ahead and save that
and refresh or let's try ctrl
f5
and there you go hello ui5 again
now what we're going to do is we're
going to
create a button and we're going to
create an event
um that when that button is clicked
we're going to have a pop-up
and we're going to do that in a separate
controller
so what we're going to do is we're going
to pull out just like we did with the
view
we're going to pull out the controller
reference it
in the view and create a new folder
called controller and have our
controller available there
so there'll be one view and one
controller
so let's go ahead and jump into our
view first
and now that we're in here we need to
create a
reference to that controller so we're
going to call it
we're going to call the controller
name and that's going to come from sap
um ui demo
walk through
and then dot controller for our
controller folder
and app because we're going to call it
app.controller
and now that we've got that we're going
to
remove our text control and we're going
to put in a
button now we can just call this because
this button is also available in the s
in the sap.m library so we can call that
straight away just like we did with text
so we're going to button
and we're going to give it the text
property so the button will have text
inside of it that says
say hi for example
then we want to call the press event
by calling this press and we want to
call the method so we're going to create
all the
function rather oh sorry the on show
hello
event and we're obviously going to put
something
in that event to happen i.e the pop-up
so we're going to call this on show
hello has the event
and we can go ahead and save that
let's format brilliant
now what we're going to do is create the
controller
so under web app we've got our view
and we're going to create a new folder
called controller
then under controller we are going to
create an
app dot controller
dot js because we're going to write our
controller in javascript
now that we're in here um
we can start with our sap
dot ui dot define
and once we've opened that up
we need to bring in our
mvc controller assets
so we are going to call sap
slash ui slash
core slash mvc
slash controller
now that we have that we're going to
call
our constructor function and we're going
to pass
in the controller which is
from here and this is the again sap
naming convention
and now that we have our function we're
going to call
use strict
and as i said before the use strict
is a literal expression which was
introduced with the
ecmascript 5 and
a sort of line of items and it basically
tells the browser to
execute the code in a sort of strict
mode
and it effectively helps detect
potential coding issues
um at an early state
at development time and um
i mean for example it will make sure
that variables are declared before
they're used etc
um and so it's just there to stop sort
of basic javascript pitfalls
um and so that's its function
so now once we've got that we are going
to
return controller
dot extend
and once we've got that
we are going to close it off
and let's just move this out the way
and that should be fine
so everything we've got here
uh is sort of the standard or basic
uh controller layout um
we're pulling in our controller assets
here
we're pulling it into our constructor
function we're telling it to use
strict um so we're keeping our
javascript
uh fairly strict in this case then we
want to
return the controller and
um once we sort of we're going to return
the controller and extend it
by adding in the functionality in this
next section which
is where we're going to put our on show
hello
our on show hello event
so um once we've got that
we can go ahead and add our um
sap dot eui dot
demo dot walk through
so we're going to call where this
controller is actually located
as we did with the view
and that's our app controller so now
that we've got that we're going to call
or we're going to rather
implement the logic for our event so
we're going to go on
show hello
and that is that event is going to
trigger a function
where we are going to show
a native or vanilla
js alert
and just like we did before alert
hello there
and we can save that so
um in our view everything we've got
is here we've now got a new button with
the text that says hi
then when you press that button call
this event
and this event is kept in the controller
which is
referenced here here's our controller
we've pulled in with the sap naming
convention the
all the controller bits and pieces that
we need passing into the constructor
function
our controller
using a strict javascript and
we are going to return
our extended controller which is located
here
and in doing that we are going to just
simply we've just simply got one
function or one event which
has a function that alerts as of another
javascript alert that says hello there
so we're going to go ahead and save that
and save our view as well
and if we press ctrl f5
and now if we go ahead and
press on the button
there you go there is your alert
and that's all be implemented within the
new controller that we've created
now we're going to move on to modules
and
modules are just basically resources in
sap
so we're going to add a module resource
here
which will allow us to call the message
toast from it from the sap.m library and
replace the alert
with this message toast so
we go ahead and put in a comma
and add the new module sap
slash m message
toast
then we need to take this pass it into
the constructor
like that and we can get rid of
this alert and we can call
message toast dot show
hello there
and we can go ahead and save that
then we can go and press ctrl f5
and if we click our button here's our
message toast to the bottom
right now what we're going to do is
we're going to add
an input field control to our app
we're going to bind its value to the
model
and we're going to bind that same value
to the description of the input field
and we're going to use that
using a json model so
just like we worked with the modules
before we need to add the
json model to that same section so
in the appcontroller.js
we are going to go and add sap
slash ui slash
model slash json slash
json model now that we have that we need
to bring it into our constructor
function
so we just take that
and add it in there now
what we're going to do is we're going to
call
or we're going to access the on init
event so this is the initialize event
that happens right at the beginning
which is where we're going to
sit and create our local
json model so we call the on
init event in the controller
we pull our function and we open it up
oh whoops i put that in the wrong place
just pop that down there
and we can just pull this up a bit
higher
there we go don't forget between your
functions to
put a comma um now that we're in here
we are going to
set the data model
on the view to do that we are going to
first create a variable
let's call it odata and
we're going to set this in json format
so we're going to put in a recipient
for example and that recipient
is going to have a property called name
and we're going to just say
let's just say ui5 for example
now that we have that
we've got this odata
json object here now
um we need to create the json model and
then we need to assign it to
our xml view so that the xml you can
access it
so the first thing is to create a model
a variable for the model and we'll call
it a model again we're using hungarian
notation here
and we are going to sit with the new
json model that we brought in
so new json
model and
placing that odata object we created up
here which is in json format
then we call this
dot get view to get the view
itself and then set model
model
and that's it let's
go ahead and format lovely
now we're going to go ahead and in our
view
we're going to create the input control
so underneath our button the input also
comes
from the sap.m library so we can just go
ahead and add that
and the properties are going to be the
input value so the value you'll see
in the input itself and now
is where it gets interesting we're going
to pull it
directly from the odata model
so we reference the so now we have the
odata model ready and attached to our
view
we call the recipient
and inside the recipient was the name
property so
here's our recipient slash name property
and that's it really um
so now we've got the value there
um we are going to add the description
description that's brilliant
equals hello
and note we're using we're combining the
text and also
a call from the json model itself
and again slash recipient
slash name
and we also want the value to update in
real time
and so we call the value
live update property
set that to true
and finally let's give it uh sorry um
i don't need to add the commas here
and finally let's give it a
width of
60 for example
lovely so we've got the value um
that's going to be in the value section
of the input control
it's going to say in the description
hello recipient name
uh the value live update is true so as
we update it you'll see in the front end
it'll update automatically which will
make sense now
and we just set the width to 60
so we can go ahead and save that
and it's important to note that
for the live update to work we need to
make sure we have set which we already
have this compatibility version
to edge you can also sit another
property called
um sep ui binding syntax to complex
uh you can do either all but this does
um a few other things
including setting that complex uh
binding as well so
we don't have to worry about that now if
we go ahead and save
our server is still running so if we go
to
browser and press ctrl f5
ah i forgot to close off
the input control it's quite important
so if we go ahead and ctrl f5 again
so now it says hello there still
now if we adjust this
it should say hello ui5 now it's not
doing that so let's have a look at our
xml
and see where we've gone wrong
so hmm
ah there was a spelling mistake so
um that's very important check your
spelling
so now if we go ahead and save control
f5
so there you go you've got hello ui5
which is in the description
and you've got ui5 in the value
over here now if i had to type something
like
john it changes in real time
and there you go
now what we're going to do is we're
going to add
the translatable texts and
what that means is we're going to move
all of the or
some of the texts depending um to
a to an i18 file so a separate resource
file that we're going to
point to in a minute and this way
you can keep all of your various texts
that you would reuse throughout your
application
and you can have them in one place where
you can then translate them into
different languages
and yeah that is called
internationalization and it's done with
an i18n
file so sap have got a special resource
model that they use or that they
let you use and to achieve that and
let's go ahead and add it so the first
thing we need to do
is we need to go into our files
and under the web app file or with a
folder rather
we need to add a new folder called i18n
and under there we're going to add our
i18n
dot properties file
and there we go now that we have that
um we're going to put in our two texts
so
we'll call the first one show hello
button text so that'll be for our button
and that'll be save hello
we don't have to worry about um
apostrophes and and quotes and things
like that here
and then we're going to call another
item hello message
and that's just going to be hello whoops
and that is how we add
a parameter which we'll use in a second
so our i18 properties file is set
that's all fine now
let's go ahead and pop back into our
controller
and let's get rid of that for now
now we need to bring in our module so
just like we did before asap
slash ui slash model
slash resource because it's a resource
model
and r-e-s-o-u-r-c-e
model there you go and then we need to
bring it into our constructor function
just after json model
and now we can work with that in here so
the first thing we need to do is
we need to sit and all we need to create
and set the model
so the first thing we're going to do is
underneath our model here
we'll go ahead and create the next one
so we're doing this all
again in the on init event which is the
initialization event that happens at the
beginning
when the app loads so let's put in our
comment
set 18 in model
on view then let's create our variable
i 18n model
[Music]
that's camelcase and that is going to
equal
new resource model
and let's open that up and our
properties are going to be
bundle name
and that's going to be
dot ui dot demo
dot walk through just like we did before
dot i 18 n for the i 18 n
folder and the i 18 n
file itself
then we're going to
move on to the supported locales and
that is going to be left as an empty
object
and let's just do that
oops
square brackets and that's going to be
left empty for now
we don't really have to worry about that
and the fullback locale will also be
um kept blank um but i
think these are um you need to put these
in there they're ex they're uh you just
you you have to put them in i can't
remember the word but
yeah they need to be there um
so that's all fine now that we have um
our i18n model we need to set it to the
view
so this dot get view
dot set model
and it's the i18n model and we're going
to give it an alias
and we're just going to call it i18n so
the second part here is just simply
giving it an alias
and then that's how we'll refer to it um
further down so um we can go ahead and
save that
now on our on show hello
event we are going to
read the message and we're going to read
the message from our i18n model
and we're going to show it so let's
put that down and we're just going to
put in our comment
read message
um
from i18n model
so um let's go ahead and create
our bundle resource bundle so our first
variable
is object bundle
and that's going to be this dot get view
dot get
model and again calling the alias
i 18n
and get resource bundle
get resource bundle
which is from our bundle name here which
we've specified
then we're going to create
another variable called s recipient
and that's going to be this git view
dot get model
dot get property
and we're going to get our recipient
name so recipient
name and
once we've got that um
we can so obviously this recipient name
is coming from our
original json model up here
slash recipient slash name now
we're going to create our message so var
s m is chip
equals o bundle
dot get text
because we want to get the text from our
bundle
and we're going to ask it for the hello
whoops hello
message and i'll show you that now hello
message
and that comes from
[Music]
and that comes from the
hello message here that's what we're
referring to
and then we're going to add in
the s recipient which we have
created here as a variable
so we can finish that off
and now we're just going to show the
message
and just like before message toast.show
and we call our variable s message
and we save and so if we go ahead
ctrl f5
and then if we click on say hi
hello ui5
hello coming from here
and then if we had to change that to
something like hi
refresh again it would say
hi there you go
so um let's just put that back to hello
um now what we're going to do is we're
going to
change our button text to reference
the show hello button text and to say
hello where it says say hi at the moment
so we need to go back to our view
and in our button it says say hi
what we do is we reference it like
this so now we're in the xml view and we
reference it as an
i 18n
show let's rather copy it so we don't
make any mistakes
show hello button text
and so this should now pull from the
resource bundle which the
view has access to and if we save
refresh
ah sorry it's not a slash
it's a greater than sign my apologies so
the greater than sign
sits here and if we go ahead and refresh
it changes to say hello and there you
are
so now what we're going to move on to is
the component configuration
and what that means is we're going to
take all of our
ui assets and we're going to encapsulate
them in
a component file that is independent
from our index.js file
and so we make it independent and
reusable
and so from now onwards we're going to
be accessing all of our resources
relative to this component file
so we're going to take pretty much
all of this data that's on init
in the initialize section and we're
going to put it to be loaded in the
component file
so under web app new file
component.js
and now that we are in the component
we are going to open up our sap dot
ur oopsie
we're going to open up our sap dot ui
dot
define
and now that we've got that we need to
pull in our ui component module
so that comes from the sap namespace
slash
ui core slash
ui component
then um we
need to pull in our json model
so just like we did before
it's sap slash
ui slash model or we can actually just
copy paste it i think um
just to be on the safe side then we also
need to add our resource model for our
i18n
internationalization file we can just go
ahead
and pull this as well
now that we have that we need to open up
our constructor function
and we need to pull all of these values
in
so the first one is our ui component
oops
then we need our json model
and finally our resource model
then we can go ahead and open up our
function
making sure to use strict
to run that strict javascript check
and then once we have that
we need to call return
ui component
and we need to extend it just like we've
done in the controller
extend and we're going to extend our
component file
so sap dot ui dot
walkthrough dot component
because it's in the the component file
is not in any folder it's just in the
web app folder so we can
call it directly from there
then
we need to add a few parameters
so the first one is our metadata
and that metadata object is going to
hold
our root view so we're going to tell it
which view to use
as our root view
root view
and our per our attributes
our view name
but we need to put these in quotes view
name
and that's going to be the sap dot ui
whoops sap dot ui dot
demo dot walk through
dot view dot app
because it's in our view folder and it's
the app.view.xml
and the rest of the variables will be
type
the risk the attributes are will be type
and it's an xml
view
we wanted to run asynchronously so ace
a s y n c
true oops we don't need quotes for
booleans
true and we're going to give it an id
of app so id
app now that we have that
we can call our let's just save that
first
so now that we have that metadata
in we can go ahead and call our
initialization
event reference that
which is init and we open up our
function
and in this function we're going to
first of all call the
function of the parent
parent the parent ui component from
sap and that is ui
component just like we pulled from
here ui component
dot prototype
dot init dot climb
and we give it this
arguments
then we start setting our data models so
set data models
now i'm going to be lazy and just copy
this directly across
so our first one
is that
and then once we have that um we need to
set that onto the view so i can pull
this
as well
now once i've got that i can set the i18
model
so set
the set i 18n
model and again i'm going to go and copy
and paste from our controller just to
make sure i've done it properly
and i'm going to go ahead and save and
so far our component is looking good so
we can double check everything is fine
and what's the problem at the top here
[Music]
um
uh we just need to
get rid of that perfect
now let's go and tidy up our app
controller
so all we need now is to leave this
behind
because this controller is going to
handle the events that happen
specifically with the view
so we can take away
all of this including the
um on init event
and let's just format that
perfect so now all that's left is our on
show hello um event call
and our function that runs underneath
there
and now once we've saved that we need to
go
back into our index.js file
and what we're going to do here is we
need to create the component container
instead of the view um in our index that
in the obviously the index.js file
and that's going to instantiate the view
for us um according to the component
configuration so the configuration we've
got in our component
so let's go ahead and get rid of
that let's go ahead
and get rid of everything under here
perfect so first things first we need to
bring in our module
and that's going to come from snap ui
core component
container component container
yep then we need to take
the component container and pass it into
our function and once we've done that
we can create a new component container
open that up and our attributes will be
name and we're going to call it
zap.ui.demo.walkthrough
and we're going to add our settings
and that's going to be
we're just going to give it an id in
this case
so id equals walkthrough which is fine
and then we need to tell it we want it
to run asynchronously
so a s y and c is
true as the boolean
and finally according to our index.html
we need to place
at content
all right that's a method call so we
need to put the dot there
place that and so
we've done everything we need to do in
our index.js file contour
calling our new component container that
component container is going to then sit
um in it's going to be put in the
index.html
in the body section with id
content we've moved all of that logic
from our controller into the centralized
component.js file where we do things
like
in the inner function get all of our
models and bits and pieces and assign it
to the views
including our i18 model as well
and
our controller is now far more tidy and
far
what it's now going to do is
specifically work with the view
and anything that happens in the view
rather than what's happening in the app
sort of to begin with so it's it's
separating the doing the separation of
concerns here
and only handling what happens in the
particular view
that uses this controller so let's make
sure everything is
saved and if we ctrl f5 to refresh
uh it looks like i have incorrectly
entered the view name it's sap.ui.demo
dot walk through my apologies uh
now if we press ctrl f5 again
ah so the issue is
me trying to copy paste things across um
which
can sometimes lead to issues that
specific issue
is we shouldn't be getting any view here
we should just be setting the model
directly
do apologize for that copy paste when
you can
um but try and check your work and try
and retype it because it
stops you making silly mistakes like
this
so now if we control f5
we are working again there we are
right now um coming in from the
prerequisites
and the step one um we're going to talk
about the
descriptor or rather the manifest.json
file
so all application specific
configuration settings will
now further be put in a separate
descriptive file
called the manifest.json file and what
this does is it clearly separates the
application coding from the
configuration settings
and it makes things even more flexible
so for example with sap
fiori all applications within
fiori are realized as components and
they come with a descriptor file
and this is there so that they can be
hosted within the fiori launch pad
itself
so the fury launch pad acts as a sort of
container
and instantiates the app without having
a
local html file for all the
bootstrapping stuff
and so instead the descriptor file is
passed
and the component is loaded into the
current html page
whatever that may be and so this allows
several apps to be displayed in the same
context
and each app can define local settings
such as language properties supported
devices
and pretty much anything else you can
think of
and we can also use the descriptive file
to load additional resources
and instantiate models like our i18
resource bundle
or any model for that matter so
we don't have to create one because
we've already created it in the
beginning
and what we're going to do now is just
check a few settings
so the first one is in the sap.app
section
the version we've got is 1.1.0 which is
fine for now the id
is going to be sap.ui.demo
dot walkthrough
and it's an application um the i18n
now has a specific attribute and so
that comes from our i 18n folder
and it's the i18n dot properties
file
then we we're just going to give this
application version whoops
1.0.20
just fine and now
the title of the application
is going to come from
the i18n file which we're going to edit
shortly
but this is where this is what it's
going to be called
app title and we can also put a
description in
description and
let's just put our comment for now
whoops and inside there we're going to
call it app
description
[Music]
and so we've got our version and
everything that's fine
now we need to go to the sap dot ui
section
and um you can set things like icons
favicons
and all sorts of other bits and pieces
the important thing for us is device
types so
if you decide you have a very complex
table app you might go
i only want it on desktop and i want to
say tablet and phone to false
but in this case our app is going to be
pretty straightforward throughout the
whole course so we're going to set these
all as true
then um we have supported themes which
is fine
so there are quite a few um attributes
here which we're just going to skim past
but they obviously do
a whole bunch of stuff but it's just out
of the scope for this particular course
the next section is sap ui5
and this is where we are going to
determine things like our models and our
root view
etc etc so we're going to start off
with our root view
and this is going to be
an object and in that object we have the
view oh sorry this is in json format so
it's
everything has to be in quotes so it's
view name
and it's
sap.eui.demo.walkthrough.view.app
and um we're gonna do the
type of view which is you guessed it xml
then we're going to set it to run
asynchronously
async true
and our id
is going to be set as app
now you'll remember all of these
settings because
they come from one of our previous files
so let's just run through everything and
we'll go and tidy up
our component and controller in index.js
files shortly
so we've got our root view then let's go
and find
dependencies so dependencies
our minimum version for ui5
we're going to set it as 1.6 but again
depending on whichever what project
you're working on this
can be set to pretty much any version
then the libraries we want is
in this case just sap dot m
and we're not going to worry about
minimum version for now so we can just
close that up
and we don't have to worry about a
second library at this point yet so it's
just one library that we've got
and now finally we can deal with our
models
first one being i18n
and the type is a resource model
and now we are going to put in our
settings
and our settings are going to be
in this object
bundle name
and our bundle name is asap dot
eui dot
model dot
resource model
whoops and then we need our supported
locales
and our fallback locales so
supported locales
and again this is empty but we need to
put it in
anyway uh whoops
and fallback
fullback locale
is going to be that for now
so put a comma there and we go ahead and
save
now we've got all these settings put in
here
we need to go ahead and change a few
things in our index.html file
and now that we're in here we need to
first change our on
init call and so this is going to be
we're going to change to rather module
sap
dot ui dot core
slash call rather slash
component
support so now we're giving it support
for the component running it through
like this
then in our body section we need to
create a new div
and we need to assign that div a set of
properties
to allow it to be used by the ui5
runtime
so we're going to add in the first
attribute we're going to
add in is data
sap dot ui
dash ui dash component
and we're going to call data
name and that is going to be our sep
dot ui dot demo dot
walkthrough
and our data id
is going to be container
and we're going to add in our final
attribute
data settings
and that's going to equal
oops what the attribute we're going to
use is
id and
we're going to call it walks through
and so we can go ahead and save that
now where we referenced
our app title and app description and
because we're now using i18
properties from the manifest we need to
go
back here and add them so
let's add so this for a comment you use
the
hash and we'll call this is for our
hello panel
hello let's put capital panel
and here is our app descriptor
stuff and so let's
copy that directly across
title app description
and app title is going to just be
hello ui5 app
and whoops app description
we'll just say a simple
test app to learn ui5
and you can do whatever you want
right if we go ahead and save that
now we need to go to our component file
and remember all of this stuff within
the metadata
now we are going to get rid of it
and all we're going to do is reference
the manifest
and so all of that data is now going to
sit and be referenced from the manifest
itself
and if we go ahead and save there should
be no change to our app
oh and before i forget we need to make
sure we go ahead and delete our index.js
file
because we no longer need it
and we also need to make sure that we
remove
our i18 model call
here because that's
already now set in the manifest
so if we go and press ctrl f5 again
oh show hello button text so
uh let's see what's gone wrong
so let's go and have a look at the
manifest
and see what's happened
so models 18 in type resource model
settings bundle
ah that's the problem
my apologies i probably copy pasted this
incorrectly
but in our bundle name we need to
reference our actual
i18n file so that's sap.ui.demo
dot walk through
dot i 18 and dot i
18
so now if we go ahead and refresh there
we are
we are back to normal
right so now what we're going to do is
we're going to add
um a page and panel
to our view xml file and we're going to
put the input
inside of it and we're also going to put
a few more controls around them so that
we aggregated properly and
everything looks nice so what we're
going to do is we're going to start off
with
an app control then inside that we're
going to have the pages control
and you can have we're only going to
have one but then you have your
page control inside underneath the page
control you have your content
and inside your content you have your
panel with a few properties
and then inside of that you have your
input
so let's start off at the top
and we're going to
just hit display block
to true
then once we've done that
we're going to add app
um and let's just
close that off
oops
then once we've got that we can add our
pages
and close that off
inside here we are going to have page
and we're going to give that an
attribute of
title
equals and we're going to add this to
our i18n
internationalization file and so we
reference that with i18n
home page
title for example that's perfect so we
close that off
and we close off our page perfect
now under page we need to have content
and now within the content of the page
we're going to open up our panel
and it's important to note the
spelling here as well these two need to
be in
capital so just check um
your controls as you go along and read
the documentation
so now within this panel we're going to
have
header text equals
again from the i18n file
i 18n
hello panel
title and
once we've got that
we now just need to close off our panel
oops capital p there panel
and then we need to add the content
again
underneath our panel and again if you
read the documentation you'll know
exactly
what needs to go underneath for example
a panel will need to have content etc
etc
so we add content
close it off
and we can take our complete input
and we can add it straight in there
let's do a bit of formatting
and there we are so if we go ahead and
save
and control f5 to refresh
there you are so you've got your um
oh i see the button is sitting at the
top here because it's not
in the panel here's our button so
let's take our button
add it here just before the input
watch it's fine then let's refresh again
and there you are there's your help
hello panel title
oh we still need to add um our i18n
bits and pieces here so let's go into
our i18n properties
and if we scroll down
we'll add our
let's take this one first homepage title
and we'll call that uh ui5
walkthrough and
let's go ahead and grab the hello panel
title
pop that in equals and we'll just say
hello ui5
save again refresh
oops need to watch my spelling save
again
control f5 and there you go
so now what we're going to do is we are
going to
deal with the shell control and bring it
in as a container
so we're going to add a new root element
for our um xml control here
and what that shell is going to do is
it's going to take care of the
visual adaption of the application um
and it's going to do that in relation to
the screen
size and you'll start to see a sort of
litter box shape so you'll see the
borders on either side
and especially well this is obviously on
desktop screens
but for the most part you can add a few
more um
sort of background details here if you
want and this is a sort of introduction
into how
the fiori shell is involved in the
application
but for now we're just going to go ahead
and add the
shell the shell here
and we're going to go ahead and
close that off
and let's format the document
so now that our stuff is sitting within
the shell control if we press ctrl
f5
you can't really see it on the screen
but if i expand it a little bit
there you go now you can see the app
itself
which would have just been sitting in a
single page an app
you now have this background sitting
here which is kind of where the fiori
would sit
the fiori shell would sit around
so now we're going to deal with
margins and paddings and what you'll see
here
is the panel is sort of glued or stuck
to
the side here which doesn't necessarily
look all that nice
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use the sap standard
classes and we're going to use them
to sort of dynamically
and sort of you know in a a way that
works well with the sap controls
themselves
and we're going to apply those sort of
stylings on top of it
so if i switch back to the code
we are going to first go and find our
panel
and we're going to add the class
attribute
just like we would um anywhere else
and we're going to call the sap specific
sap
ui responsive
whoops responsive
margin or the sp specific margins
and we want the width
to be auto
perfect now we're going to add some
styling to the button itself
so if i just get this in line here
so now we are going to assign a
class uh to the button that again
calls the sap ui small margin
so again this is just a different type
of margin that sp has available so sap
ui small
margin end and then
we are going to go down to
under the input
if i just get everything
down here
just so you can see everything a bit
more
clearly underneath this
input we are going to add a text control
and in this text control
um oh sorry that should be capital t
e x t and
i'm going to call the text attribute
equals and we're just going to say hello
uh again um calling from our model just
like we did before
recipient
slash name and we just need to add a
slash in front of recipient
um so again we're pulling that
from our um our model
um then we're going to assign this
a class as well and we're going to use
the
sap small margin class
so sap u i
small margin
and we'll just close that off
so now if we go ahead and save
and refresh
hmm what's the issue here let's go back
and
check the code panel
content button on show hello ah here we
go
apologies
that should be at the end they're
closing off uh
that button um control
so let's go back and control f5
there you go so now you can see the text
is placed here
there's some nice padding there and this
button is just
off here instead of attached directly to
it making the
use interface user interface much
nicer to look at
so now we're going to move on to custom
css
and theme colors but
this particular section is something
that
must be treated with a fair amount of
caution i would recommend using the
standard sap theming and css that you
have available any sort of custom css
i think is probably more important if
you
need something very very specific on
your app that needs to be achieved
through css
sap will not
offer to me have it maintained as it
runs through so as new versions come
through you will need to recheck your
css
to see that it actually works so
we're going to run through this section
just to show you how it actually works
but it's very important to remember that
this needs to be taken with a pinch of
salt and
try and keep to the sap standard as much
as possible from a
layout and css point of view so
the first thing we're going to do is we
need to go to the manifest.json file
and we need to look for our sap ui5
section
and we need to effectively turn on the
resource
for css so um underneath your resources
your css will be here if not you need to
add it
underneath resources and our uri
is going to be
[Music]
we haven't created the file yet but it's
going to sit under
the css folder and we're going to call
it style.css
which is fairly standard we don't have
to worry about
an id for it so that's the manifest
done now
we let's go ahead and create
our css folder which will be under
the web app folder so css
under there we're going to create a file
called
style.css and this is where we're going
to put our code but before we do that
we need to just like we do a normal css
we need to go and label
the different classes in our view
so if we go ahead and find our view.xml
we're going to add some
the stylings in three places so the
first one is in the app itself
so we're going to call this class
my app
demo wt for walkthrough
then we're going to add some styling to
the button where we're going to bring it
a little bit closer together
and so we're going to replace the
standard sap
margins and we're going to call this my
custom button
um and then um we're going to add a
we're going to add a control um and
we're going to
it's a formatted text control
so um we're going to
remove this well actually
we can affect we can effectively just
edit this it's fine so
formatted text and
um this needs to be labeled as
html text oops
html text and that's just going to call
our hello recipient name
and our class um
is going to um we're going to
keep the small the sap small margin
there
but now we're going to add the color the
custom color
so first we're going to call this the
sap
or first we're going to call rather the
sap theme
highlights
as color so
um let's just pop this on a weight
um i need to open this up rather so
now we're just chaining our classes here
so we've got our class here now we're
going to apply the sap
theme highlight um and then the as
color and from there
we're just going to add the custom one
where we'll just call it my
custom text
and we can go ahead and our parentheses
there and save
now we need to go and add our style
our particular styles here so we're
going to reference
the first thing we're going to do is
reference the left to right
part of this so you reference that
whoops square brackets
dir equals ltr
and now that we have the left to right
section
um we need to add the my app
demo wt
and we're going to add the dot my
custom button
dot sap m btn
and we're going to open that up
and now that we're in here we are going
to say margin
[Music]
right and we'll give that a rim of 0.125
perfect and we're going to do the exact
same thing
but for the right to lift for things
like arabic languages for example
and that's going to be right to left
and save that now we're going to
reference the
um we're going to add for these
particular classes we're going to add
let me just add them in here demo
walkthrough
and my custom
text and in here we're going to
add display
inline block for that formatting and we
want uh
let's just do font weight
set that bold
perfect so if we go back to our
application
and control f5
hmm all right let's go back and take a
look at our
code so left to right
that's all fine right oh sorry this
should be
margin left um
because this is going to be right to
left so the margin will be on the other
side
um but that won't stop it let's check
our manifest
css ah
that comma shouldn't be there so let's
go back and save
and control f5
there we go so there we've got some bold
uh some the font being bold which is
perfect
that's all fine that's also looking good
you can see this has changed a little
bit that's got a little bit smaller
but it's it's still got a bit of a space
there um
so yeah that looks good
right so in this video we're going to be
dealing with nested views
and as the app becomes more complicated
um we are now going to
compartmentalize or move things around a
little bit
and in this particular case we are going
to take the
um panel that we created uh which is
over here
and we're going to put it in a separate
view with its own separate controller
and then we're going to tidy up the
current controller or main controller
and
we're going to do a reference in this
section here
so the first thing we're going to do is
we are going to create a
new view which will be done inside of
our view folder
and so we are going to call that
the hello panel
dot view dot xml
then we are going to
[Music]
um open up our
xml tag here view
and we are going to reference the
controller that we will create shortly
enter the name equals sap dot
ui dot demo dot
warp rube
dot controller for the controller folder
and we'll call the controller hello
panel
as well then the xml
ns tag is that
and that's going to be referencing our
sap.m library
and now we just need the xml ns
with the mvc alias and we need to bring
in the mvc artifacts
so that's sap.eui.com.mvc
perfect whoops we can close that off
mvc
lovely so now that we have that
we can go back and grab our
full panel here and we can just take the
lot of it
we can cut it and paste it
right in here let's format everything
and now that we've formatted it that
we go ahead and save so before we create
the controller
we just need to reference it now that we
have taken it out
of the view of the main view we're going
to nest it in here
and we're going to call mvc just like we
did above
xml
view and we're going to give it
the we're going to add the attributes so
the first one is you name
um and that's going to come from zap dot
ui dot demo
dot walkthrough
dot view dot hello
panel whoops so again referencing our
folder structure
view folder and the hello panel file
we can close that off
so that is fine
now let's go ahead and create our new
controller
and this is going to be called hello
panel dot controller dot
js
and now that we're in here we are going
to call sep
dot uh whoops
sap dot ui dot define
and we can get rid of these
so we need to call the controller module
and also the message toast module
because those are the two we're dealing
with so
say p slash ui
core mvc slash
controller oops
and sap slash
ui oh sorry
that's sap slash m slash
message toast
then we need to bring in
these two into our constructor
lovely and now that we've done that we
can go
back to our standard app controller
and we'll tidy this up in a minute but
we can then pull this out
and that'll stay as is that's perfect
brilliant
so we just need to wrap this up
in our controller logic so return
controller dot extend
and we need to extend our sap dot
ui.demo
dot walk through
dot controller and referencing the new
controller itself oops hello panel
[Music]
controller
and
i'll just shove that back in here
so it'll look exactly the same as the
other controller
to run our formatting
lovely so
that looks fine
all good this one is going to sit
fairly empty for now we don't need the
message toast module
anymore so we've just got our empty
controller
this is all fine extended
and let's go ahead and save
save i don't need the component manifest
or css
i don't need that so let's check that
referencing our view
and our brand new view here so we've
saved everything
now if we go ahead and have a look at
our code i mean our app output
and we press ctrl f5
so the panel content is now
refactored into its separate view
and there are no visual changes from the
last step
but you can now see we've extended
things and made the app a bit more clear
to understand
so in this section we are going to move
on to
fragments and we're going to run
a dialogue fragment specifically
so uh dialogues i mean fragments are
a fantastic way to create reusable
artifacts that
you can use without the need for a
controller
so a good example would be if you've got
a
form that needs to be opened at a
certain point
and you need a read-only version or an
editable version
you can do that very quickly and easily
with fragments
and you can design each part of the form
to be read-only or editable based on
each individual fragment
so in this case we are going to create a
dialogue just a simple dialog
and we're going to call it and call it
specifically from
our view and we're not going to we're
obviously not going to have a separate
controller for it but we're going to use
our current controller to
handle the logic so
let's go ahead and find our hello panel
view
and in there we're going to create a
button
and that button is going to be used
to call this new dialog fragment
so we'll add some attributes to it
and we'll call this the give it an id of
hello
dialog button
[Music]
then we will let's the text will
obviously add to our i18n
file so we'll reference that in as the
i18n greater than symbol
and we'll call it the open
dialog button text oops
so let's go ahead and add that to our
i18n file
as we go along
and let's uh let's call that um
say hello
with a well let's just say with the
dialogue
lovely so that's that
uh then uh
then we need to call the um the press
event so if someone presses on this
button this is what needs
to happen and it's going to be on the
we'll call our event on open
dialogue and
let's add a standard sap class
and just say sap ui
small margin end to give us a margin at
the end point
and we can go ahead and close that off
so let's just format this perfect so
that's a line
brilliant so uh let's now go ahead and
actually create the fragment so
in the view section we are just simply
going to add it like we would any other
view
you can have a separate fragment folder
if you want um but
in this case we um we won't
so this is going to be called the
hello dialogue dot fragment
dot xml
brilliant now in here we open up our
fragment
with call fragment
definition
and we call the xml
ns and we bring in our sap.m library
and we need the um the sept.ui.co
library as well so
xml ns sap.ui.cor
and we'll give this an alias sorry that
needs to be an equal sign
and this will be an alias of core
and that will equal that
brilliant and let's just close
that off
perfect so now that we have that
we're going to call the dialog control
from the sap.m library and because it
doesn't have an alias we could just
call it as is so
dialog and we're going to give it an id
of hello dialog
and we'll give it a title
[Music]
of hello
and we'll call the recipient name again
from our model so slash recipient
slash name and
perfect and that's it
this is your little reusable fragment
defined and obviously you can add a form
in here or whatever you want
but in this case it's just a dialog
so now we need to move on to our
controller and we're going to be using
our hello panel controller specifically
so here we need to add our comma
and call our new event which is on
open dialogue
and we add our function oops
function
and now we're going to go ahead and
call this dia call the fragment but
we're going to load it asynchronously
so i'll explain as i go first things
first
is to declare a
a view a will to get it um a reference
to our view
and we just say this dot get view
perfect now we're going to create
the dialogue lazily
um and to do this we're going to say
if this dialog exists
open it or else create it and open it
so if
oh sorry so the first part is if the
dialog
does not exist so if you cannot say
the spy id and the dialog id
open it's going to go ahead and
physically create it if it doesn't exist
so
if this or not this by
id and it's the
hello dialog
so if um this my id hello dialog
does not exist
then oops
then we're going to load it
asynchronously load a synchronous
if i spelled that correctly a sync
no yes it is right load asynchronous
xml fragment
and now we're going to call we need to
load our module first so
now we're calling the fragment module so
we need to make sure we add that
that comes from the sap slash
ui core fragment module
and then we need to go ahead and bring
it into our constructor function
fragment perfect
so now we can call the
fragment dot load
and go ahead and open that up
and now we're going to call the
i we're going to add the the attributes
id and that's going to be the
view that will be the id of the view
rather
dot get id
and then name
and the name of the dialogue
fragment is sap.ui.demo
dot walkthrough dot
view dot dialog
again referencing our home folder
the view folder the hello dialog which
exists there
and then we're going to use a promise so
once this has
got everything it needs um
we then oops
call a function
and we reference our dialog
and add it as an importing parameter
to this function so this is referencing
the fragment that we just loaded in the
promise
and we need to do two things we
need to connect the dialog
to the root view of this component and
we do that by calling overview.add
dependent and then we go oh dialog open
it's as easy as that so just so you can
see what we're doing
connect dialog to the root
view of this component
including the models
and the life cycle
and so we call oh view which is
referenced
up here so we've now got a reference to
our view
add dependent
dependent sorry
and calling the dialog so it's now added
as a dependent
and then oh dialog
dot open
and now that we have that um
so we've now called the fragment we've
then
uh so now if the the it doesn't exist
this hello dialogue fragment we load the
fragment
and then after the promise we then add
it as a dependent
to the view and then we open it
if it does exist
else so now we're coming back to the top
of our if statement
else
this dot by id
hello dialog
open so if the dialog does exist
just simply open it so it works it works
either way
so we go ahead and save everything
there we save our fragment
then let's go ahead and test it
ctrl f5
so let's um press f12 and see what went
wrong
so now that we're in the chrome console
if you see an error that looks like this
with all of your
xml code here it's very likely that
there's an issue with your xml somewhere
some small mistake
so let's go back and check
our code so
um ah okay
that shouldn't be there for starters
uh and let's check our fragment as well
fragment definition chord dialogue
i haven't closed off my dialogue
properly
let's save that so now let's see
if that has had any effect
there you go so check your xml um
for small mistakes but here's our new
say hello with dialog button
referenced with the i18n file now if we
click it
there you go this is our little fragment
with hello ui5
working perfectly
so now in this section we are going to
create a fragment callback and what that
means
or in this example when you click this
button
we want to have a little button here
that says close
this dialog and to do that we need to
connect this fragment to the current
controller
that we've got so it doesn't have his
own controller but it can be connected
to our
current controller and so you can open
it and close it
as you as you want so
let's go ahead and head back to the code
and now that we're here let's go to
our hello panel controller and
where we've loaded our fragment let's
connect it
to this controller and by doing that we
just call
controller this
and make sure we have our comma there
then we need to create the
um the function or the event
that says when you click on close close
the dialog
so let's find
the end of this
and let's create our on
close dialog event
and that is a going to call a function
with no importing parameters and
it's as easy as going this by id
hello dialog
dot close
there we are let's do some formatting
perfect now
let's go back to our new fragment
and in the dialog we are going to
so within this dialog you have and
obviously you just need to read the
documentation to see where i found this
but
um you can effectively add a button in
here so
the way you do that is you call
begin button oh sorry i just need to
close off the dialog
dialog
so now within the actual dialog itself
within the initial attributes that we
call
i'm going to say begin button
and in there i'm going to add my button
and that button oops
that button is going to have the
attributes text
equals and we're going to reference our
i18n
file and we'll call this
dialog close
button text and let's wrap that up
so let's go ahead and add that to our
i18n file
which is over here
and we'll just call that okay for now
so that's fine
then the next attribute is going to be
the event when you press so the press
event
and that's going to be the on
dialog event and that'll be reference
now that is referenced in our controller
now that we've actually connected the
controller
so that's fine
dialog fragment is fine let's check our
controller here
that's all good so
let's go ahead and check it
ctrl f5
and if we click on say hello with dialog
so let's have a look um let's press f12
and have a look aha it looks like
another xml issue so let's close this
and go back to the code and let's have a
look at our dialogue fragment
so we've got our dialogue that's
all closed with our attributes begin but
ah i haven't closed this off
so uh let's go ahead and
close it off so first thing we need to
close off our button
and then we need to close off our
begin button begin button
now that might this sort of thing might
seem like a silly mistake
um but when you are writing uh massive
views and nesting them
and calling fragments these um will
pop up from time to time so it's very
important to
double check everything
um
and that looks good so let's go back and
test
ctrl f5
hmm still seems to be the same issue so
we press f12
looks like it's still the xml so let's
go ahead and check the code again
and see dialogue
i haven't closed off the top portion of
my dialogue
again silly mistake
there we are so let's go ahead and check
for a third time
and see if this works refresh
click on say hello with dialog
so um it looks like we have another
issue
um so let's take a proper deep dive and
see
what the problem is
um hmm i've made a
spelling mistake here this should be
close button let's go and change that
here as well
save and save so
dialogue everything begin button button
that's closing clock
again silly mistake this
should be there i'm pretty sure that was
the main issue so let's
let's go ahead and have a look and
refresh it again
and see if we click the say hello dialog
there you go so again check your xml
but here's our dialog fragment and if we
click ok
it closes it and
that's it working great
right so now we're going to move on to
section 18
icons sap ship with
quite a wide variety of icons to choose
from
and in this section we are going to put
them in two separate places
so you can see how they work so
the first one is in the hello panel we
are going to add an icon
to the button to one of the buttons
rather so
in your first button your hello dialog
button
let's go underneath id and just like any
other attribute
we're going to add icon equals
sap icon and this naming convention
is found um in the sap icons
sort of web page which will be linked in
the description
sap icon um
forward world and we can go ahead and
save that then let's go ahead and add an
icon
to our fragment and we can also adjust
the size so
let's go ahead and just before the begin
button
again referencing the documentation when
dealing with dialogues and fragments and
all of that
we would add in a content section
and close that off
and then under this content section we
would call
a core oops core
icon and now you can see where the alias
has come in so
this is coming from um the set.ui.co
library
and we've referenced it here with xmlns
but then we've given it an alias of core
so when we reference it
in the xml itself we have a prefix of
core
and then we add our icon so now you can
do this with all sorts of different
libraries
as you bring them in like zap.ui.table
etc
so how do we have that let's add some
attributes
so source will be
sap icon
and this one will be the hello world
icon now we can tell it
the size and we'll give it a size of
eight rim and we'll give it
a standard sap class
and we'll set the margin to sep
ui medium
margin and let's go ahead and close that
off properly
so now that we have that let's go ahead
and check
so we're going to go ahead and refresh
and there's our first icon in the button
the little world
and if we click there's our second icon
so in step 19 with the
reuse dialogue section we're going to
expand our reuse concept
and invoke the dialogue at the component
level
so what that means is if we take a look
at our controller here
this section where we load up
our fragment we want to take it and we
want to add it to the component
because if we didn't we would have to
rewrite this every single time
in each of the different controllers if
we wanted to reuse this in different
parts of the app
so by taking this and putting it
directly in the component file here
we can reuse it wherever we want and
only run the code once
so let's go ahead and do that
the first thing we're going to do is in
our component file
we are going to reference our
um our hello dialog
javascript controller which we'll build
in a second
but let's go ahead and add it
as a module at the top so now what we're
doing is we're referencing the root
folder
and we're calling the controller folder
itself
and inside there will be the hello
hello dialog file which then
we will bring through into our
constructor function
here
so let's go ahead under the controller
and create our new file
called hello dialog
sorry um we need to
create a hello dialogue dot
js oops
if i could spell hello dialogue dot js
there we go that is everything we need
there so we'll come
back to that in a second let's go ahead
and continue with the component
um and that'll make a bit more sense now
so now that we're in the component we
need to create
the or call the dialog rather
and also add an exit function and exit
event handler as well so
let's call set dialogue
and then it's this underscore
for so whenever you use underscore it's
a naming convention for
private methods in javascript so
hello dialog and that's going to equal
new hello dialog
and we're going to pass it in the get
root control
so get root control
that is fine so
um let's just set that so we've set this
in the um in the init function so it's
going to be called
when it initializes then
we need to add an exit function an exit
event sorry
with a function that says
this dot
private method hello
dialogue dot destroy and
delete this
dot underscore hello dialog to
obviously really clear or clean things
up
so let's just format that
lovely um so now that we've got our exit
function
let's add our open
hello dialogue method sorry
my spelling is not fantastic
so on open hello dialog
function
and within this we're going to call this
private method this dot private method
hello
hello dialogue dot open
brilliant so we've got everything we
need set
out in our component now what we're
going to do
is we're going to take all of that logic
that we had
in the uh where is it here in the
jalapeno controller and we're going to
expand it
and make it reusable in its own
javascript file
here so um
we start off with sap dot ui dot
define
dot ui dot define
and we open that up
and we bring in our modules so we've got
um
the sap
slash ui slash
base managed object
which will make sense in a minute
and this is sap slash ui
core slash fragment
brilliant then we're going to open up
our
function here
and we're going to pass in the r2
modules
and pass in fragment
brilliant so now that we have that in
there
we can open this up and as always use
strict
then we are going to just like we did
with the controller except this is now a
managed object it's return
managed object dot extend
and we're now going to extend our hello
js file
and that is referenced at sap dot
ui dot walk
through dot
the controller folder and
hello dialog for the hellodialog.js file
and once we're in there we can open that
up
and we can start off with our
constructor
and that is going to be a
function that brings in the view which
we which we would have passed
in uh and i'll show you that in a minute
now but that's a
parameter coming in and
we reference and we we create we
allow this private attribute so this
overview is going to equal the
view we just brought in which is over
here
then we're going to specify our exit
function our exit event sorry
and then this is function
and this is going to be delete
this underscore overview
perfect then
the next one is going to be open and
this is where we're going to add
all the logic from the the
previous controller so under open
we get function not passing thing in
and we're going to create our view
variable
which is view overview and we're going
to pull this from our private
private attribute overview
oops now just like we did before
we're going to create the dialogue
lazily
and if
o view dot
by id just like we did before
hello dialog
so if it's not there this buy id hello
dialogue that hello dialog is not there
open up our if statement and we create
our
um fragment controller variable
controller fragment controller
and we open that up and that's
on close dialogue
and we pass that function
and so it all makes sense in a minute
and it's quite a lot to take in as we go
but just stay with me
and dot by id
hello dialogue
close
great so we've got that there
that's our fragment brilliant
now we're going to
load the xml fragment asynchronously
asynchronously just like we did before a
synchronous xml
frame
and again fragment
dot load
and in here we're going to pass in the
id
um which is
from the just from our view variable
dot get id
the name is sap
dot ui dot demo dot
walk through
dot view dot
hello dialog
and that is that again is our folder
structure so it's referenced in the view
folder
in the hello dialog fragment
and then we give it the controller
we give it a controller rather and that
comes from the
o just like we typed above the o
fragment
controller which is
over here remember that
and once we've got once we've fulfilled
that promise
then function
passing in the dialog
the dialog above giving just giving it a
name in the param in the
importing parameter here
and we're going to connect the dialog
to the root view
of this particular
or i'm just going to say of the
component because there's only one
component
of the component
models and life cycle
lovely and so we call overview
dot add dependent
dialogue and a
dialog dot open
now that we have that there
we can run our else statement
if i put that in the wrong place where's
that
end
uh if i put that if
um there we go
my apologies else
overview dot by id
hello dialog
open dot open
and let's go ahead and save that
else else else no we don't need that
close that
and let's just format our document
brilliant so we've got everything we
need here
um now let's go ahead
and reuse it so the first place first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to put it back
um in the hello panel
controller where we used it before so
the functionality will be the same
then we're going to add a little button
at the top right which will also reuse
it and you can see how easy it is
and again there's a lot of code here
that i'm going through um
if it doesn't make sense just keep
re-reading through it rereading through
and follow the chain of where things go
and it will make sense um so i really
encourage you to take the time to really
really understand this
because if you can get your reuse
components all running through the
component file
you've got yourself a pretty robust
maintainable application
so let's go ahead and save that and
let's go back to our hello panel
controller
and we are going to get rid of pretty
much
everything
else
and all we do so now on open dialogue
when that
um event is called all we do is
this dot get owner component
calling the component get owner
component
open hello dialogue
that is literally it so this open hello
dialog
sits here and that runs through our
whole process that we've just spent all
this time putting together so we can go
ahead and save that
now let's go back to our um
our application controller which is the
controller assigned to the apple kind of
just so you've got your shell and then
your app which you'll see at the top
line
let's go to where is it here so before
we add it in the controller
let's go to our app view
and inside our
page we have our content section and now
we're going to add
header content so
header content
and close that off
edit content and in
here we're going to add a button
and we're going to give that an icon of
sap icon
hello world
and then we're going to call the press
event and tell it to call the
on open dialogue event which we'll
specify in the app
controller shortly on open dialogue
so let's go ahead and take that name so
make sure it's correct
and again don't forget to close off your
button or any of your controls
go ahead and save that um
so then let's go back to our app
controller
and all we're going to do is
on this event let's just
place that down on open dialog
call our function and in that function
just like we did in the other controller
this dot
get owner component
getting the component file
uh or getting the instance of the
component rather i suppose it'd be more
correct
hello dialog
and there you are so this event
um is whichever event you have in
whichever of your views or controllers
or whatever it is
all we've done is we've allowed us from
anywhere
in the app instead of repeating all of
that code to just
call this to get our fragment and
now that we've done that let's go ahead
and test it
ctrl f5 to refresh
so first things first let's see if our
button works
all right it's not working so let's
press f12 and see what's what
cannot read property of open in the
component so
let's go back and check our component
and see so open hello dialogue this dot
hello dialogue
ah spelling mistake again
so let's go ahead and save that that
should probably work
now refresh
right that's working
no it's not closing when we click the ok
button so let's have a look
controller
hmm
controller so let's see there's probably
an
issue in our fragment perhaps
let's see so
let's um see i probably typed
in the controller at some strange point
so let's quickly
control law search that aha
there's the problem so um
i've spelled incorrectly again
so if we go ahead and save that
and let's close this and refresh
and try one more time brilliant so that
works
lovely let's try our new little button
here reusing it
there you go
now that we have a good structure for
our application um
let's go ahead and add some data so now
in section 20
we're going to look at aggregation
binding
and what that's going to do is we're
going to add some json data
and we're going to reference it in our
view
and show a list of invoices
it's a as simple as that so let's go
ahead and
create our data and we're going to do
that
in our web app directly and we're going
to create a
file called invoices.json
and there's quite a lot of data here so
i'm just going to copy it across which
you can do the same um directly from
um either the github repo or you can do
it you can pull it straight from the
sap uf5 walkthrough whichever suits you
so here we've got some data product name
quantity extended price etc etc
now what we're going to do is we're
going to reference this data
in our manifest and create a model there
so let's just go ahead and save this we
don't need it anymore
now if we go and find our manifest.json
file
and if we look under the sap ui5 section
models what we're going to do
is we're going to create an invoice
model and we're going to
tell it what type of model it is and it
is a sap dot
ui dot model.json.json
model whoops
json model and
the uri or the reference to it in our
folder structure
or the location in our folder structure
is straight in our root web app folder
so we just reference invoices
dot json which is
where is it yet which is you see it's
just above invoices.json
so we can go ahead and save that
now what we're going to do is we're
going to
create an invoice list view and then
we're going to
reuse or reference it in our app
specific
view so let's go ahead
and go to our view
folder let's just close some of this up
underneath our view folder we're going
to create a new file called
in voice list
dot view dot xml
then in here just like we've done with
all of our others we're going to open up
our mvc
tag view
and we're going to reference xml ns
and we're going to bring in our sap.m
library and our mvc artifacts as well
so xml ns again
using the alias and just like before
sap.eui.com.mvc
lovely so let's just close this off mvc
view
brilliant so
now that we have that we are going to
open up a list control
and that's going to have some attributes
starting off with header text
and we're going to pull this again
directly from our i18n
file following
following the naming conventions there
and
let's call this invoice list
title and let's go ahead and
um as we go along add it to our i18n
file
and let's give that a let's just
make sure we know what we're referencing
here
invoice list
inv oh i i apologize
and this is just going to have a title
of in
voices brilliant
so let's close that
and now if we go back um
to our attributes let's give this
a margin class
of sap ui
responsive margin
which i use quite a lot actually
responsive margin yes that's correct
we will set the width
to auto working in tandem with the
responsive stuff here
now comes the aggregation binding part
and all we do is we call items so the
items in your list
this could be a different attribute
depending on what
control you're using this particular
control uses
items so again read your documentation
but
the items are going to be from our model
and we're going to reference our model
invoice slash
invoices
and so what that's doing is our
invoice model which is um
available here because we put it
together
in our manifest.json file
and
we're calling the invoices
um which are over here so the invoices
are is the is the um the json
object effectively and inside of that is
all of these aggregated
items which we're then going to display
so
that's how we reference it there
now once we're finished with that
let's just close off our list here
we now want to decide how we want to
display those items
and to do that again referencing the
documentation
we have an items control
and let's just close that off
and inside the items control we have
something called an
object list item and so um
let's just put it in and i'll explain
shortly
object list item
and we're going to give that a title
and that's going to be invoice
quantity
and oops
invoice oh sorry i'm uh
referencing that so now we're chaining
these two together invoice
product name
so what we're doing is now that we have
our items available
we want to display them in the item
section
as an object list item and the title
is going to be a combination of the
invoice quantity
and the invoice product name so
go ahead and save that and that'll make
much sense when we actually see
when we actually see the output
so now that we have this let's go ahead
and put it in our
app dot our app xml view here
so here's the first one we called
and you guessed it we're going to call
the other one in the exact same way
mvc
xml view
and the view name
is going to equal sap dot ui
dot demo dot walk through
dot view dot invoice list
in voice list
close that off
and now let's go ahead and test it
refresh all right
it looks like we've run into an issue so
let's press f12 to get into the console
um nothing particularly clear
here so let's go back and check
what we've got so
let's have a look object list item
invoice quan
there's a spelling mistake excuse me
quantity
quant it yep that's correct
but i don't think i don't think that was
the issue let's check our manifest
ah needed to add a comma
between the section and the section i
apologies
so that should fix it let's refresh
no looks like we have an issue with our
xml
in our app view so let's take a look
there
view name aha
quotation mark is in the wrong spot
let's save that pretty sure this will
work
now and there you go so
um here's your list of invoices
all laid out nice and neatly here this
is the
quantity and the name with a little x
there
just as we defined in
our view
so the next section um we're going to
move on to is
number 21 and that's data types
and here what we're going to do is add
on
um a currency
value and pull it directly from our
model
and so if you had to look in the
json format you'll see that the
quantity and price is in this sort of
very simple
standard format what sap allows you to
do is to set
um these as currency values um based on
locales and and that sort of thing
so we're going to go ahead and apply
those uh that formatting and those data
types
on top of the json model values we've
got here
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to find
our invoice list view and
what we're going to do here is we're
going to attach this to a controller
which we'll create shortly
so we're going to specify the
controller name
and that will equal sap.ui.demo.walk
uh walk through
dot controller
dot in voice list
brilliant so we've referenced that so
let's go ahead and
just create an empty controller for now
um dot js
lovely so we'll get back to that in a
second
now in our object list item
where we had our title specified
we are now going to add or
we're going to include one of the
attributes which is specific to the
object list item
the number and once we're there we're
going to add
the data type and formatting so
we're going to start off with the parts
attribute
and in here we're going to specify the
path
to the value that we want to deal with
so
there's two important points here the
first one is we're going to
grab the the invoice
extended price
and then once we've got that
we're going to add the currency but in
order to do that we need to add a
currency model to our um
view and to our controller itself so
we're going to do that shortly in the
controller but just so you know where
it's coming from
it's not coming from the json model
itself
the invoice json model rather
so it's coming from view
currency
and that all looks fine
then we're going to tell it what type so
the data type and again you can check
the documentation for what
types data types you have we're
specifically going to use the currency
data type
from scepter.guide.model and
so whoops
let's just specify it like this
sap.ui.model.type.com currency
and we're going to add some formatting
options so
format options
and we're going to show we're going to
tell it not to show the measure
which is fine
false and
um that's all good so
we have that there that's right and
the number unit
is going to be the uh
currency symbol itself which comes from
whoops to reference this
correctly view
currency all right
so now that we've set the formatting for
the
number and the number unit
which are all attributes of the object
list item
let's go ahead and jump into our newly
created
invoicelist.js controller
just like all the others sap dot
ui dot define
and we're gonna pass in the two modules
the first one is controller and the
other one is json
the json model so sap dot
uh slash ui slash core slash
mvc slash controller
and the second one is the sap slash ui
slash
model slash json slash
json model
brilliant then we open up our
function and we add in
the controller oops
and the json model
and once we're inside here we're going
to use
strict strict javascript checks
and we want to return just like all the
other controllers
return controller dot extend
referencing this particular controller
sap.ui.demo.walkthrough.controller for
the controller folder
and invoice list
and now that we have that
we can go ahead and add the on init
event
um we want at that event we want to call
a function
and in this function we want to create a
new json model uh with the currency and
the euro
for example attached to it and then we
want to set it to the model
so that um we're able to call it
at this point that's why we're creating
that's effectively why we're creating it
so create a variable called ou
model
that's going to be a new json model
and that has one um
value called currency
euro because why not
you can obviously add any value you want
and once we've got our model
we're going to say this dot get view dot
set model
and we're going to say overview model
and we're going to give it a simple to
an easy to read alias that we'll
remember just called view
so again setting your model and then
giving it an alias so you can refer
to it using this alias in your view
which we've done
here is our alias
so let's save that save that
perfect now
let's go ahead and check
ctrl a5
all right let's take a look and see what
the issue is
um failed to load
invoice.controller.js from
ah it's a naming issue
so what i've gone and done
is i haven't called this
using the correct naming convention it's
actually invoicelist
dot controller
dot js that's very important
and while we're here let's just double
check our controller is actually
um functioning properly so function
controller json model
return controller dot okay another
spelling mistake
that's extend except.you ought to demo
that walkthrough controller invoice list
fine our models there
this.getview aha
missing the brackets very important
so let's go ahead and save that and
re-run
that should probably fix it let's see if
anything else comes up
no let's check again what's gone wrong
and caught in promise something's gone
wrong in the xml
so let's check
so object list item title aha
it's supposed to close off the xml
control over there
again silly mistakes but they will come
up quite often
so now let's go ahead and refresh again
and there we are it finally works so now
we have our
87 10 6.85 and then from the other model
we created in the newly created
controller which we needed to rename
properly with controller init
in the name we've added on the euro
so there your prices are
now we're going to move on to section or
step 22
expression binding now expression
binding is incredibly useful
for adding little
components of logic to your various
attributes in your
xml in your ui5 controls
to determine whether or not something
needs to happen so
in this example we're going to take the
um
we're going to take the object list item
and attach an expression that says
if the number is the extended price is
greater than 50
give us a number state of error
or give us another state of success
depending on the outcome and
that attribute error or success will
determine whether or not the number
state is green or red
and consequently whether or not the
actual number in the output is green or
red
so um it's quite straightforward and
very useful once you get
going and again you can apply this to
pretty much any attribute you have
obviously within reason so um and again
check the documentation on expression
binding but once you
once you understand it it's fairly
straightforward so
we are going to open up with an equals
dollar sign
and the dollar sign is going to be used
to reference the
invoice extended
price item or value
then we're going to use shorthand in
javascript to say
if this value here
is greater than 50
uh question mark
in quotations error so
if this evaluates to greater than
50 set this as set the
value of number state so if this
runs as it is error
will basically be the value of number
state
which is what the attribute would be
expecting as one of its
possible values
or if not
if the extended price is less than 50
the value of number state must be
success
and in doing so it will be green
so this is specific to this object list
item but obviously
you could just change these values
depending on the control
that you're using so
if invoice extended price is greater
than 50 um evaluate
if true error or put the
value put the text error in number stage
or if it's false put success
in number state so if we save and
take a look at our code again i mean
take a look at our app again
refresh
okay we've run to a small issue
number state ah
there's my spelling again something you
will probably come up with
quite often so we've
spelt that correctly hopefully now if we
save it
and refresh
there you go above 50 evaluate to error
and error means it needs to be red
that's the number state and green if
it's
um evaluates to false and is less than
50.
there you go
now what we're going to do is we're
going to add something called a custom
formatter and a custom formatter is just
a javascript file that handles slightly
more complex
formatting options so what we're going
to do is we're going to add
underneath each of underneath the euros
symbol here we're going to add the
invoice status
and we're going to format it accordingly
so let's go ahead and create
our actual new formatter
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to create
a new folder and a web app
called model um and normally you would
have a model folder
but in this case we don't so we're gonna
we're just going we're just going ahead
and creating it um once you've got your
folder
you then add a file called
formatter.js
and uh just like your controllers um
when you want to pull in this particular
object you
oops you open it up with sap dot ui
doctor
phone
and we're just going to run straight
into our
function
and don't forget to use strict
and we are going to return we're just
going to simply return
our logic here and so
um the s we're going to obviously um
status text we're going to deal with the
status text in this particular part of
the formatter
so we're going to run our function with
s status passing in the status
um into the formatter itself
then um we need to get
the resource but so again we're
referencing the resource bundle
because um this is the um where we're
going to reference the actual invoice
status and
so we can translate it etc etc so
resource bundle
and that's equals this dot get
view dot get
model and we're getting our i18n model
dot get resource
bundle
now that we have that whoops i just need
to
close that off and get rid of this
now that we have that we're going to use
a javascript switch status
oh sorry a javascript switch
statement rather for the status
and we're going to pass in the status we
brought in
and we're going to start off with
case hey
and we're going to return
resource bundle dot
get text
invoice status
hey so we're going to pull that back in
then we're going to i'm just going to
actually i'm going to
rather type it out because we're not
wanting to make any more mistakes
case b
return resource bundle dot
get text
invoice oops
invoice status
b
and case c
return resource bundle
dot get text
invoice status c
and closing that off with default
return
a status
brilliant so let's just format that
lovely so case a give us back this from
the i18n file case b
status b kc status c if it doesn't fit
any of these
just simply return the status
so now that that's done we need to go
into our
invoice list controller so we can
get rid of all of this stuff
and here's our invoice list controller
now we need to bring in our formatter
and to do that we reference the
model
formatter
and we just go ahead
and add that in there
and above the on init function
we just simply pop in our formatter
and reference the formatter
perfect so we've now got the formatter
available making the formatter available
through our controller to the view
now let's go and find our invoice list
view
so we don't need component hello
dialogue
with our view invoice list view
good stuff and again
we're adding this in the object list
item
and we're adding a control called first
status also from the sap.m library
and we can close that off
status
and we're going to add another control
of the control within called object
status and that's going to have
an attribute of text equals
and now
this is where we add our logic so i'm
closing that off just to make sure
now here we're going to specify the path
and the path is invoice
status so that is the
uh where's our invoice list
view
so here's our status this is what we're
referring to with a b and c
um so that comes out of there
and once we have that we
obviously call our formatter
and that's the formatter and
the formatter obviously has
the status text and that
is what we are going to reference
uh where's my view over here so
formatter the formatter
object itself and the method here or
event
and we can close that off
save so we've got our first status
control here with an
object status here the text that it's
going to show
is going to come from the invoice model
and specifically the status field
and the format we want to use is located
here
and that's the method we're going to
call inside of it
and now that we have that
let's go ahead and jump into our i18n
file
and we are going to
just go back to the
uh with the formatter we're just going
to take these
and
[Music]
add b and c
equals so invoice status a it's going to
equal new
invoice status b is going to equal in
progress
and invoice status c is going to equal
done so we should see these
in our front end application so let us
go
and have a look and we go ahead and
refresh
all right so we've popped another error
out
let's have a look at the console
all right it seems to be an issue in our
javascript file
so let's go and have a look at that
so we've got our first status here
that's fine that's all closed or aha
so if you look at the object list item
it runs all the way through to here but
because we're now adding in
another separate control
we need to
close that off like that
and we need to wrap it up
in a full object list item
so instead of the control running all
the way to this point
because we've now added a separate set
of aggregated controls here
we have to close it off properly just
like we would normally
now that should fix things let's have a
look control f5
all right it looks like we've got
another issue so let's check the console
and it looks like a spelling mistake
so let's go back to the code
and have a look here
with our formatter
there we are let's just double check
resource bundle resource bundle
that looks fine so let's go back and
check
ctrl f5
there we go working now so there's new
in progress in progress and done all of
our status is loaded here
and run through a separate javascript
formatter
in the next section section 24 or step
24
we are going to look at filtering and
we're going to look at an example of
filtering
uh through a search bar a text search
bar
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to add the search bar
inside the um or just above the
list of invoices and then we're going to
run
a event on the search attribute
um and in the invoice list controller
we're going to add the filter there and
apply it
so let's go ahead and head
back let's just close some of these tabs
getting a bit cluttered
and let's go ahead and open up our
invoice list
view
and in here we are going to
first of all find
our list and we need to give it an id
and we'll just call it invoice list
and now that we have that we are going
to add
a control called a header toolbar
and again from the sap.m library we can
just go ahead and add it so it's called
header toolbar
and let's close that off
now that we have our header toolbar we
need to add
another control underneath it called the
toolbar
and close that off
and within the toolbar we are going to
add
three controls a title a toolbar spacer
and a search field so we'll have our
title spacer
and the search field on the right hand
side so
let's go ahead and add our title
and give it the text
again from the i18n file
invoice list title
and let's just double check that that is
in our i18n
file yes there it is there
so that is fine
we can go ahead and close that off let's
add our toolbar
spacer
perfect just to close that off
and now let's add our search field
with a width of 50 50
should be fine
and now we need to
uh in the search attribute so or search
event rather we need to
call our on
filter invoices
event
and let's head on over to
our controller which is where this will
be triggered
so in our invoice list controller
we're going to need to bring in two more
modules
the first one is the sap slash ui
model slash filter
and also from
sap slash ui slash model
filter except we're going to bring in
the filter operator
as well operate all
yes then let's bring it into our
constructive function
perfect and now that we have that
uh let's go ahead so here's our on init
event
and we're going to run uh this on filter
invoices
event afterwards on
filter invoices
and that's going to be a function and
now we're passing the event so we're
going to pull
some data from the actual
event that is getting triggered
and that'll make sense in a minute so
we need to first first build the filter
array
and and what that means is
we need to build um a filter based
on whatever query has come out of that
search bar
so whatever person types in the search
bar needs to be
put into a filter query and then applied
to
the model itself so we start off with
oops start off with a
variable called a filter
and that's blank
then we need to create our query
and now we're referencing our event
and we're getting a parameter
from the query
so we're getting the param the parameter
the query parameter itself and then we
say if
yes query so if there is something in
the query
a filter dot
push so standard vanilla javascript push
a method here
new filter
and in this filter so now this is the
the sap part
the filter we're going to call product
name so we're telling it the product
name is what we want to filter
then the next thing is to say the filter
operator
dot contains so now
the filter operator contains is saying
it must contain
the values that we've now that whatever
they've typed in the
search bar itself and we're passing in
the
query
perfect and now
we need to do our filter binding
so we create our first variable which is
the list
and we get reference to this by this
by i d
in voice list
then we need to get
a reference to the binding itself so
whatever is bound to this list
i.e the model and so we'll call this o
binding
equals o list dot get
binding items
i remember the when we bound the model
to this list
it was bound in the items section or
attribute
and so we get a reference to that
binding
and what we do then is say o binding
filter
and we pass in the filter
and it's as easy as that so um we
create our filter over here and we push
the query
into the filter itself so now this af
this a
filter has the filter that says the
product name
must contain whatever is in the search
bar
we then get our list we get whatever is
bound to the list
in this case the invoice model and we
tell it
binding filter according to this filter
and if we go ahead and save
both of these and refresh
we should now be able to type something
like
pineapple and
it filters based on p-i-n-e
and if we had to remove that let's try
milk
and otherwise there you go there's your
filtering
so now following on from the previous
step filtering
we're now going to look at sorting and
grouping
and we're going to do that in
the invoice list view itself so we're
going to
sort it and then eventually group it but
we'll sort it first
and all you do is you find in the items
attribute we add a little bit more logic
here
to allow it to do that so the first
thing is we need to specify the path
and that's obviously our
model here and the invoices inside that
then we need to add a sorter
and inside the sorter we reference a
path
to whichever column we want to sort in
this case
the product name for example but you can
sort by any column
and let's just open that up
and save that and it's as easy as that
so we've got the item path
we've got the sorter we're telling it
what to sort by product name column
and if we go ahead and save
refresh our page
you can see red c
m p s all sorted
and to group it we are going to go back
to the code
and let's change this to
shipper name comma
group attribute and we set it to true
it's as straightforward as that so if we
go ahead and save
and let's pull up the application
refresh
there you go sorted
and grouped by shipper name
right so in this section step 26
we're going to look at a configuring a
remote odata service
um but because we're running on our
local machine
we are going to configure it and run it
to an era called a cause area or
cross-origin
resource scripting something along those
lines
and it's just something that comes with
local development in ui5
and you wouldn't normally run into this
issue in something like sap cloud
platform because you would configure
your
remote edit remote odata service in a
destination inside cloud platform and
then reference that from your app
so if you're working in the web ide
that's fine you can go ahead and
create your destination and connect it
if you know how to do that
that's out of the scope of this
particular course so
um we are just simply i'm just simply
going to show you how to do it
and run through the steps so you can see
how it's done
and then we're going to move on to step
27 where we'll configure
a mock server which is
a bit more complicated but it's the best
practice and also it's a great way to
help you understand help you to
understand your back end service better
and
prepare your app etc without also
without putting any
additional resources on top of your
current live
remote service that you might be using
so let's go ahead
and jump into the code
now inside the manifest there are two
things we'll need to do
first one is set our data source and the
second one is
create the model using the data source
so
we're under sap.app and under data
sources we're going to call this
invoice remote the uri
would be whichever url you have for your
remote
data service in this case we are going
to pull the
um the northwind
service which is in the i'm just going
to copy it across from the sap
walkthrough
which is where you can find it then you
would need to add
another attribute called
type and
it is an o data type
then under settings
we're just going to go ahead and add the
oh
data version
and the version is 2.0
and now that we have that um
we can then take this data source and
build a model on top of it
under the sap ui5 section
under models where we've got our a i18n
model
and also our local model which we'll
replace and then put back
so we can delete that and we just call
the data source
attribute
and it's as straightforward as that
so if we save and we go back to our
application and refresh
obviously it's going to fall over and if
we go to the console by pressing f12
you can see here is this cause error
that i was referring to
um so this will come up on your block if
you're obviously building this on your
local machine
so you the um you can on the
sap walkthrough step 26 page
it gives you ways to overcome this
that's out of the scope for this course
because
at the end of the day we want to run
with our mock server
and build our app based on that so for
now we're going to ignore it please feel
free to go ahead and use it if you want
otherwise next we're going to move on to
creating a mock server
right so now what we're going to do is
we are going to move on to
step 27 where we will configure our mock
server
and all mock server is is a little bit
of javascript
and we would run a instead of running
our index.html file we would run a mock
server.html file
with a few minor tweaks and it's just a
case of taking
for example our invoice json data which
we'll actually remove from here in place
in a another folder and we'll just
reference the same data but in a
running actual mock server to
to sort of simulate a proper back-end
service
and so obviously this is sap best best
practice and
it's highly recommended to do it this
way so you can run your
stuff locally without touching any data
or having to rely on a remote service as
well which
could be an issue at times so
let's go ahead and jump straight in and
create
our indexed html well our mock server
html file
to do that um we're going to create a
we're going to add to our folder
structure
and doing so we'll clearly separate
the testing logic from everything else
and this might look quite complicated as
we go along don't worry
follow along as best you can get it
working and then after that go back and
check and see how things work and
connect and and how they run through the
different steps
so just bear with me in terms of the
complexity at this point it's very much
worth it once you
once you get going so under the web app
folder we're going to create
another folder called test and within
test we are going to add our
mock server
dot html and we are going to find our
index.html and we are going to literally
just copy
all the data across for now
then once we have that we can start
making our changes and distinguishing it
from the
the actual index.html file
we'll add something like uh sap a ui5
walkthrough test page
uh then we just need to adjust our
folder structure
um our root folder structure here and
then we just need to change
uh the module here to be
sap slash ui slash
demo slash walk through
slash test slash init
mock server so this will be our
javascript file where we'll
um start our process uh which will make
sense in a minute
so now that that's all done our htr
mock server html page is complete
now under the same test folder we're
going to create another file
called you heard it init mock
server dot js
which is what we're referencing from the
html file
and in here we are going to call sap ui
define
and we are going to call um
a another module or file from
our local servers folder which we're
going to create in a second
local service mock
server and once we're in there we're
going to open up our
function
and we're going to pass this
in
and now that we're in our function as
always we need to use
strict for our javascript
and now we're going to
initialize uh the mox server
and we're going to do that by calling
mock
server up here
mock server dot in it
and then we are going to in
initialize the embedded
component on the html
page which will make sense in a minute
and that we run through
just like we did before pulling in our
component
zap dot ui dot require
sap slash ui slash call
slash component
support so now we want to make sure our
component runs
properly um
then we are going to move on
from here now that that is complete
underneath web app we're going to create
another new folder
and create our local service so we
create a folder called
local service
and under there we want to first of all
add our mock data which is the
json data that we've been using for the
invoices
so we're going to create another folder
called mock
data and under here
we're going to create a folder i mean a
file called invoices
dot json and
we're going to pull everything from here
put it there and that means we can go
ahead and delete our invoices.json file
there because we're going to be pulling
it from here
inside of a box server so we can go
ahead and save that
then underneath local service again we
need to
create a another file called r
metadata dot
xml file and this
metadata file is it's going to look
quite complex and i'm effectively going
to just copy it
straight across all this is
is deciding the skeleton or the shell of
your data so
um this because we're running a mock
server
this sort of information is now required
to build
the um the json model output
and so you'll see things like your keys
the different property attributes
i'm not going to go through too much
detail here you can have a look and
understand how it works um
and it'll eventually make sense but it's
effectively just your
your skeleton your metadata skeleton so
that can sit there and that's all fine
now again under local service we're
going to create
another file called mock
server dot js
and again this mock server js dot js
is what's coming into our initialize
javascript section here
so now now that we're in our
mockserver.js file
we can open up our sept.ui.define
and we need to bring in uh two modules
uh the first one being sap slash ui
core slash util slash
mock server
and the next one is sap slash
base slash util
slash u r i
parameters
and then we need to open up our function
bring in those two modules here
and open up our function and as always
use strict
perfect and now we want to return
and inside our return or what we're
going to return rather
is our init
and we're going to open up our function
and now we are going to
create our mock server and we're going
to create a variable called o
mock server
and that equals a new mox server
and the root
uri is going to be the
northwind url
so this is almost like our pretend url
that we're going to call
and this is just referencing how we
would normally
create our service but then obviously we
will actually reference
our um our mock server data instead so
um that's all fine there
then we need to create another variable
called uri
parameters and
this is going to be a new uri
parameters and we're going to pass in
our window
dot location
href brilliant now we're going to
configure the mock server
with a slight delay configure
mock server with
a delay and so we call
mock server dot config
oops dot config
and inside here we call
auto respond oops
auto respond
true and then we call
auto respond after
autorespond after
and we call o uri parameters
dot get
server delay to actually add our delay
in
and we put that at 500
i think it's milliseconds whatever the
case may be
then we are going to simulate things
so from here we need to collect we need
to grab our path rather so if
s path
our variable s path equals
local service
so this is the path to our local service
folder
and then we call o mock
server dot simulate
and we pass in the
s path
plus the path to our
metadata.xml and then we
also give it the s oops the s
path plus the pathway to our mock data
mock data
and then from there we go ahead and
start
our mock server
omar server dot start
and that's it we go ahead and save
and now we can go ahead and test uh it
seems to not be
working ah because we're still calling
our original
index.html file ah no
so uh because it's located within the
test folder again
this is why it's important to separate
your test logic from your
um your sort of normal app itself
is it's here and it's in here so it's
quite hard to get to which means you
have to purposely go
to it and test it and obviously when you
run your app normally it's an index.html
file so
if we click on that
here we go it's working so now our
localhost structure changes where we
follow the test folder and we call the
moxserver.html file and it's clearly
separated from our
index.html file which is
best practice so there we are we are now
running
a mock server
right so now we're going to move on to
step
28 or section 28 um and that is unit
testing
with something called cue unit now so
far
we've added quite a bit of functionality
and we probably should have been testing
it or creating tests
for each bit of functionality as we've
gone along we haven't done that
um but um
that is something that um is best
practice
in pretty much every production app
out there so um we're going to go
through it
and in this example we are going to go
through
a q-unit unit test
specifically for our
statuses so if you look at the
statuses here we're just going to run
through
a quick unit test for them
i'm not going to go into too much detail
because
um there is a whole section dedicated to
this
and it's a little out of scope for this
at this point so i'm
literally going to copy and paste the
code across and just explain things very
briefly
but this this is will need its own
dedicated section so we're not going to
worry about it too much
at this point so the first thing we need
to do is
we need to create a
a unit test to physically run through so
we're going to create a
javascript file so underneath our
test folder we're going to create a new
folder called
unit then under unit we're going to
create a new folder called
model and in our model folder we're
going to create a formatter
dot js file which is going to house all
of our actual
test testing logic as it were
so i'm just going to copy this all
across
and so um there's a few bits and pieces
that
are quite important but effectively
um all that's going to happen is
it's going to run the tests based on
these parameters and all that it's going
to do is return
whether these are correct or not as it
passes as it receives it back from the
resource bundle
and where it does that so let's just go
ahead and save that
where it does that is from a unit test
html
page which we're going to create now
so now that we now we have the logic for
our
unit test we go back under the unit
folder
and we create something called a unit
tests
dot q unit dot html
and this html page is going to be the
sort of front end of our
unit test so we've got a few scripts
here
that will make sense in a minute but
otherwise the html page is
fairly standard
what is going to make sense now
is this so we need to
basically create the javascript file for
this html
and that's going to be also under the
unit
folder and this is obviously going to be
called unittests.quit.js
and in here we're actually going to run
the call
for our full test so um
it's going to basically bring in the
formatter
test here that we've got here and it's
it's going to run the key unit test so
um
again lots of detail here yeah it's it's
uh needs to have its own
section for running for the test but
i'll let you guys read through this in
your own time
um but for the most part all we would
need to do now
is go to our app and under test
and then we will go under unit
and we would run the unit test cue unit
html
and you'll this is the page that you'll
get back so this is the html formatting
that you would have seen
and here is each of our individual tests
returning back um
essentially what we were looking for so
um again
a more detailed section uh will be
coming soon but for now this is the
sort of basics you have an html page
that runs off
um that runs this little javascript file
which eventually runs the actual unit
tests
in this file
so now we're going to move on to section
or step 29
integration testing with opa um
so just like we did with the q unit
testing sap
has something called opa-5 which you can
use for your integration testing and
sort of seeing
how things interact in the front end and
the example we're going to run through
in this section is seeing if our little
hello world dialog opens when we click
it we know it does but we want the test
to run that as well
so just like the test before in step 20
28 i'm just going to copy and paste the
code
and sort of talk you through it purely
because these
into the integration testing just like
unit testing has its own
full section to go through um and can
get quite detailed so
we're not going to get too bogged down
with it now because we just want to get
our app working
once it's working and running and we've
been through this
we can then go back and work on unit
testing and integration testing
so
we yup so we're going to test
the hello world dialogue and to do that
we need to go back to our test folder
and we need to create a new folder
called
integration
and in the integration folder
we need to create something called a
navigation journey which will make sense
in a minute
so navigation
journey dot js
and i'm just gonna like i said bring the
code straight across
from the sap walkthrough
so all that happens is
we have a bunch of boilerplate code up
here
and we have some actions and these
actions
are basically going to simulate what
happens in this case
what happens when we click the dialog
button and what should happen
so this will make sense now when we call
it from the
next section so now
we need to create a new folder
underneath integration
called pages and under here
we're going to create a new file called
app dot js
and in this file we are going to
copy in the code and all that's
happening here
is um when we describe our actual
actions
um it's it's just returning
the dialogue effectively returning what
happens when you
click the dialog button and determining
what is
a success and there you can see we're
asserting again just like we did with
the unit tests
i mean and then obviously our error
messages whether or not the dialogue
control
was um anything happened in terms of the
dialogue control opening or not
um so again quite a lot of detail here
for a separate section
but this is roughly um sort of what it's
doing
now we need to create our html page and
our our backup javascript file so
underneath the integration folder again
we're going to create an opa
tests dot q unit
dot html page and again
copying across fairly standard
html
again this is going to bring up a
similar page to the
unit test before obviously oops
obviously designed for the unit test
itself
and now we need to create one more file
underneath integration and that
is going to be our opa
tests dot q unit.js
and in here we're just going to start
our unit test
which is going to run those other two
javascript files
and obviously it's going to run that
navigation journey
which is basically
this process and this process is going
to run
and call stuff from our app.js file here
which is going to
physically run the actual integration
testing and decide what happens when
it's
what items are returned if it returns or
doesn't
give us an error message etc so
we can go ahead and save all of these
oh i've made a spelling mistake my
apologies it's opa
save that so
let's go ahead and run the test
so we can hop out of here
and instead of a unit test we go under
our integration test folder
and just like we did before we call our
html file
and we let it run and the test came back
the dialogue opened
brilliant test passed
so now in section or step 30
we are going to look at the debugging
tools
that sap have have created for ui5
specifically and they
are pretty fantastic because as far as
debugging goes um
it can be pretty painful um almost like
looking for a needle in a haystack so
to have good solid tools to back you up
can be really helpful so again in this
section it's hard to go into detail
because
um you can have a million bugs and those
bugs can
look and feel completely different for
different people
um it also comes down to your experience
with whether you find bugs quickly or
not
so i'm just going to run through
a i'm going to break a simple
item you can see it's already broken
here
but i'm going to go ahead and break it
with you so
we're going to remove this 10 euros here
and we're gonna do it like this
so we're just going to change that so
it's not extended price
it's it's a typical spelling mistake so
um now if we go and refresh the app just
like it did before
the price has gone so this is very
common and something that could come up
so um to bring up the developer tools
in in chrome you would need to install
them so you can find them from the
uh the chrome um add-on store
um and again all of these will be linked
in the walkthrough itself
um the sap walkthrough under the the
step 30 so that's fine
i've already got it installed so it's
ctrl alt
shift s and you get these
tools that pop up and there's a whole
bunch of stuff here
you get technical information you have
your control tree
um different debugging
parameters here a javascript trace if
you want to run that
you can run performance testing and all
sorts of stuff so
there's a lot to do here um but i mean
if you wanted to use it
in this case to fix this issue for
example
we can look through our control tree and
we can come and look
for our ob so obviously we're in our xml
view
and we've found our object list item and
you can see
we have um obviously a whole
stack of information here in this case
we would check our bindings to see what
the problem is
and we can see here's quantity here's
product
name and then if you look at extended
price
you can see the absolute path doesn't
match
product name and quantity for example so
if i just
oops if i just expand this
you can see the absolute path looks like
this
same for product name here it's invalid
because we haven't spelt it correctly so
i mean this is something you could
quickly scan through to see if you've
if uh you know as a quick debugging
process so now
if we go back to the code
and we found it we change it back
and we go ahead and refresh
there it's fixed and if we refresh
okay we'll need to so you'll need to
rerun this again
ctrl alt shift s
and under the control tree back to
object list item
binding info
and you can see the extended price now
has its absolute path
so very powerful debugging tool from sap
that you can use to hopefully help you
in your
any future debugging
right so in this section section 31 or
step 21
we are going to move on to the
beginnings of
routing and navigation and what we're
going to do in this step
is we're going to take our example and
we're going to add the functionality
that says when we click on an item
navigate
to a new page um and that comes with
a um a bit of config here and there
um including creating a new view um
which is going to reuse our current
controller
and we're going to extend some of the
logic there as well
so um we're now getting into the
nitty-gritty of what it means to have
a sort of master detail style app
but the detail is now sitting in a a new
page or a new view so let's go ahead and
build it
and the first thing we need to do is
jump into the code
and we need to look for our
manifest.json file
and in here we need to look for the sap
ui5 section and under there
we need to find our routing
section and if you don't have it you'll
need to add it
and then here we're going to start with
our global config
and so we are running with three
sections here so i'm just going to lay
them out for you so
they make sense we've got the
global config we've got our roots
and then we've got our targets
and these will all make sense as we go
along
so for now let's start off with our
global config
and the following attributes uh need to
be added the first one
is we need to call our router class
um and that's going to
handle all the routing from sap side
sap.m.routing.router
then we need to tell it that the view
type that we're going to be using
is xml
again sap based practice
then we need to specify the view path
oops
and the view path is going to be sap dot
ui dot
demo dot walk through
dot view that's for our view folder
that's what we're specifying there then
we need to
tell it what control
the id of our control um
and that's going to be the app so
the initial where is it here so this app
view and app controller
over here is going to be where we're
going to control
all of the routing but that'll make
sense um
in a minute and
control
aggregation
and we're going to set that to pages
and we want it to run asynchronously
so we set that to true
perfect now that we've said that
we can then move on to defining our
roots so within our roots
let's just fix this these should be
square brackets
so within our roots we need to
create our to patterns and um
what that means is um when we so
just add the first pattern here so the
pattern
is the um this after the slash of your
original url
um if it's if there's nothing there we
wanted to go to our overview page but if
there's something there like
detail or something like that this is
where we're going to
specify that so here's obviously
blank then we need to give it a name
and that's going to be overview
and um we need to obviously tell it a
target
which we'll specify in a minute
the target will be the overview page
perfect now we're going to go ahead and
add the
next pattern while we're here and that's
going to be
pattern detail
and the name of that is going to be
detail obviously
and it's target you guessed it
detail
and we're going to specify our target
below
so now under our target section um
we're going to add um our
overview
and inside our overview we're going to
give it some attributes
and the first one is the view id now
we're starting to link it with the views
themselves
the view id which is overview which we
haven't created yet but we will
and the view name
is of course overview of
the view
now that we have that we can
add the detail target
so detail open our object
add the view id
and it's going to be detailed
because we're now dealing with the
detail view
then we need to add our view name
and that's going to be detail just like
above
brilliant so we've now specified these
three sections in our manifest
specifying the roots where everything
needs to go
and each of the targets that these
rooting patterns are referring to
so now we need to go ahead and
create the views based on the
urls that we now specify and we need to
now
initialize the actual router that way
that we've got so
we can go ahead and save that then again
back into our component file and
just underneath the set dialog
we are going to create
the views
based on the url or
hash and all we're doing is calling this
dot
get router
dot inish
initialize with the zed
and that'll initialize or create our
router
that's going to control all this stuff
so
um now we are going to go into
our view folder and we are going to
create a new view and it's going to be
called
you guessed it overview
dot view dot xml
and in here we're going to open up our
mvc view tag
we're going to specify the controller
and this is where we're going to reuse
the app controller itself
controller name calls
sap.ui.demo.walkthrough.controller.app
and we're going to add in our xml ns
bringing in our sap.m library
and we need to bring in the mvc
artifacts directly from sap
xmlns giving it an alias again of um
mvc and that's sap dot
ui dot core dot mvc
and we close that off and let's close
off the entire view tag
him oops mvc
perfect now we are going to pull in
from the acceptor dm library the page
control
giving it a title from the i18n file
oops from the i
18n file and we'll call that the
home page title
and let's go and quickly add that to our
i18n file
and um
oh i think we already have it are there
we already have it perfect
we're not going to worry about that then
lovely
um so now that we have that
we can go ahead
and close that off and we're going to
add our next control
the header content
uh we must make sure we close off our
page as well
and close off our header content
perfect whoops now within the head of
content
we're going to add a button
and we're going to give that
some attributes the first one is the
icon
and that's going to be the sap icon
hello world whoops
hello world
and press equals
on open dialogue
perfect so we can close that off
and our header content is done now we
are going to add our nested views under
the
content section
oops
close that off close that off
and so we call our mv c
xml view oops
watch my spelling xml view
and the view name
is going to be sap.ui.demo.walk
through dot view for the view folder
and our hello panel
and close that off and
next we are going to add the invoice
list
mvc xml
view view name
equals sav dot ui
demo dot walk through
dot view dot invoice
list
perfect now that we have that
we can go ahead and
adjust our app view so
our app view is effectively going to be
um cleaned out
so all that's going to be left is just
the app class
um so it's going to look like this
and we can actually
just close it off like that right so now
that's all nice and tidy
just make sure we save that
and then now we're going to add our
detail view so this is going to be
called
detail dot view dot
xml and in here we're going to open up
mvc
view with our attributes xml
ns sap.m
and the mvc stuff xml ns
mvc oops
ui dot core dot mvc
lovely close that off
mvc view
and now we're going to open up our page
control
and add a title equals
i18n and in the itunes we're going to
call the
detail page
title let's go
and add that to our i18n properties
so detail
page
and we'll just call this walk whoops
walk through details
perfect so let's continue adding our
attributes
um oh no actually that's fine um
within the page so
close off our page
and now we are going to add a object
header
and the object header is going to have a
title
of invoice
perfect so all that's going to happen is
when we go to our details page
we are just going to see um the
text invoice that's all that we're going
to do in this step
um now what we need to do
is we need to open up our invoice list
and in here we need to add a new
attribute to object list item that says
when it's clicked
do something and we're going to do that
underneath the number state attribute
and all we're going to do is add
the um
type type
equals navigation
ah i just need to add that there
and so we're saying it's a the type of
the object list item is
a navigation type so that you can click
on it and then we're specifying the
press event
to equal onpress which will now add to
the controller
so now we need to go to our
invoice list controller
and in here we are going to add a
new event so here's our on init event
on filter invoices event and now
on press event
run a function passing in the event
so when you click you get a bunch of
details
and sort of things you need from the
event which you
most of the most of the time you'll want
to pass through into this function
and so this is where you'll specify that
and we just called it
event you can call it whatever you want
really
and now we're going to create a variable
for our
router that's going to be
sap.ui.core dot eui
component dot get
router for this
which is our app context
and all we're going to do now is tell it
to
nav to oops
detail that's it
so again it looks fairly complex but all
we've done is we've added in
simple steps to get us to a point where
we just tell it to move um
between the different targets and
patterns and
it's just a case of accessing the router
itself
which we've initialized before
calling the router using this and then
asking the router to navigate to our
detail page
so let's go ahead and test
just make sure everything's saved
and let's refresh
right so uh this seems to be an issue
let's take a look at the
console
um file not found
seems to be an issue
with our xml
let's have a look at the appview.xml
i don't know what happened here
but let's put back our mvc
view and close that off
and oh [ __ ] it looks like i forgot to
put the
id here as well um
that's quite important we need to give
this an idea of app so it knows
um its id effectively of the um
this particular app section so let's
save and
um refresh and see
right there we go it's a good start now
let's click
okay this still seems to be an
issue let's check the console
uncle type error cannot read property
interplay of undefined
hmm let's go back to the
code um
so this looks fine so there's probably
an
issue in the manifest i'm i'm guessing
so we've got our config roots pattern
name
target
another spelling mistake pattern
i'm almost certain that's the issue
let's refresh
there we go again check your spelling
every single time even though i'm
retyping
everything out out
it's so easy to make mistakes so double
check your stuff and again
it's normally the small mistakes that
break
the worst when you're running through
this because you wouldn't have even
picked that up in the debugger
um that was just pure pure spelling
there so
now you can see we've navigated to the
invoice page and
um we can start adding some details from
here
so now we are going to move on to
section 32
routing with parameters and what we're
going to do is
now that we're in this blank invoice
page
we want to display some actual
information about the particular invoice
that we clicked on
and so we need to pass the context of
that across
and display it in something like an
object list item
or something like that so that is what
we're going
to do in this step we're now going to
add some details
to the detail page so let's go back to
our code
and the first thing we need to do is we
need to find the um
the roots in our manifest and we need to
change the pattern
and all we're going to do is we're going
to add the invoice path
to the pattern itself which will make
sense
shortly invoice
path
perfect so now that we have
that we need to go ahead and create
or add the details to our detail
page so underneath our detail view the
first thing we need to do is we need to
add
because now we need to apply some logic
from the
controller we're now going to add a
reference
to the detail controller so
we reference the controller name and
it's going to be sap.ui.demo
dot walk through dot
controller
and detail for our detail controller in
our controller
folder now that we have that
we want to add some more attributes to
our
object header um so we're not going to
use an object list item we're just going
to run it through the object header
and so all that's going to happen
is we are now going to reference um
the um shipper name and product name and
i'll show you where those come from now
so we're just going to add the intro
attribute here
open up this and we're going to
reference the invoice
and from this particular invoice
we're going to reference the shipper
name
and again from the invoice that we've
clicked on
we want to reference the product name
perfect so we're going to see these two
bits of information
from the particular invoice that we
clicked on
so now that we've saved that
we need to go to our controller folder
and we need to create an invoice
before we do that um before we clear
create the detail controller
um we need to go ahead and add the logic
um or rather the path that needs to be
passed across all the details that need
to be passed across
to the detail controller from the
invoice
list controller so if we go across here
now this o event comes into place so as
you
press or click on the item it passes in
the context with a whole bunch of
details that we're going to use to now
pass across
so we're going to create a variable
called o item
and that's going to be o event dot
get source so now we've got
our source our item made up of the
source from the event
and then we need to now pass it across
so
we do that in the nav nav2 method here
as we nav across to detail
we open up
over here and we say invoice
path and we pull it from window
and code uri
component and we get that from
oh item dot get binding
context so we're getting the binding
context
and that's going to be called invoice
or from invoice rather and we get the
path
and we want the sub string
one
perfect so we're now riding on the
invoice path here
and we're passing in binding context
and we're getting all of our details
from here which we're now
going to consume from the other
controller if that makes sense
so now we can go to the controller
folder again and create our detail
controller
[Music]
detail.controller.js
and now that we're in here sap.ui.define
and we need to pull in our controller
module and
also our ui component so as always sap
slash ui slash call slash
mvc slash controller
and we're going to pass in the ui
component as well
oops sap
slash ui core slash
ui component
and we open up our function here
passing in the controller
and the ui component
and i forgot the comma there
perfect as always use
strict and now
again we are going to return the
controller
and that's extending
this controller dot demo dot walk
through dot controller
dot detail whoops
do not spell it in correctly detail
and now that we're in here we can go
ahead and add our controller functions
first one being on init
so when we initialize
function
and now that we're in here um
we need to create a router variable
var router
equals sap dot ui dot core
dot ui component
dot get
root term for passing in the
application context
and then we need to call router
dot get whoops
get root
and we need the root for detail
and now we're going to
attach pattern
matched and we're passing in this
dot on object
on object matched
this perfect
so this that'll make sense in a minute
but in the meantime
let's just add in our private method
here
and that's function oh event
this dot get view
dot bind
oops bind element
and the path is set to
base path plus window
dot decode uri
component so don't worry if this looks
complicated it will make sense when we
read it back
now events dot
get parameter
arguments
dot invoice
path
and then we set the model as
invoice so it
looks very complicated and it kind of is
um to a certain extent but all we're
doing
um in this section is we're just
receiving the context from the um
the previous from the on click event
of that particular item
and we're setting it over here and all
that's happening is we're allowing
we're sort of preparing it for our view
to be able to um
bind we have an aggregate have the
aggregated binding attached to it so
um it looks complicated but as you read
through
um it makes sense things like window
decode uri component etc
these are just parameters that you pass
into this method so
again it's all documented and all that
sort of thing so if you really want to
understand the detail you can go ahead
and read up on it but
for the most part it's it just does what
it needs to do
so now that we've got that
we can go ahead and test so everything
is saved
let's refresh our app
oh let's just go back there
let that run
right so it doesn't seem to be working
um and if we look into the console
we don't see anything so let's see how
the binding is
so let's run into our control tree
and let's have a look at the details um
right so there's nothing bound so
perhaps there's something wrong in the
xml
let's go back and look at the code this
all looks fine this controller was fine
let's see if you see control
spelling mistake again
controller name sept.ui.demo to
walkthrough controller
detail
right let's go back and refresh
fingers crossed there we go it works
again spelling mistakes but
there you go here are your two details
on your
detail page
right now that brings us into um
section or step 33 routing back and
history
so um there's currently no way to
or no button that says when you click
here go back to the original page we
have to use
the back arrow in chrome so we're going
to go ahead and add a back button and
the logic that surrounds that
so let's go back to
our code and let's close everything here
and the first thing we need to do is we
need to open up our detail view
and we need to add or show rather a nav
button so
in your page your page control has a
attribute called
show oops
show nav button
and we're going to set that to true
and nav we need to add the nav button
press
event and that's going to equal
on nav
back right
now let's go to our detail controller
and add the logic to make that back
button work
so underneath the detail controller
uh now that we're here um we can go
ahead
and create a new method and
all new event rather nav
back
open up our function now we need to
grab a few variables the first one is o
history
and that comes from oh i almost forgot
we need to add the modules first
apologies so the module we need to add
is sap slash
ui slash call slash
routing slash history
and we need to slot that in
here and now we can obviously access
that so
history
dot get instance
and then we need to get the previous
hash
so we create another variable called
previous hash
and from there we reference the o
history
variable we've got and get
previous hash
perfect
now we add our if statement
and what we're saying is if the previous
back hash doesn't exist we're going to
run and get the history
from the window itself otherwise we're
going to use the
router and navigate back to overview so
we're handling both
circuit both scenarios so this
previous hash
is not equal to undefined
so if the previous hash is found or
exists
we just call window dot
history dot go
minus one so we can just effectively
go back one step that's all that's
happening then we're calling it from
the window here um else
if that fails for whatever reason we're
going to use
our router and that's router equals
ui component dot get
rooter so we're just getting our router
for
our context which is why we add this
because this references our context and
all we do is call heruta.nav
2
overview
and set that as true so these are just
parameters
obviously remember we can pass
parameters back and forth like we did
with the
when we went from the overview to the
detail but we don't need to pass
anything back because
we're just going back to our overview
page and
that's it let's see if it works
so we go back refresh
let's follow our canned beans there's
our back arrow
there we go
so now we're going to move on to step 34
custom controls now custom controls are
beyond the scope of this course
um but because we're going through the
walkthrough itself
i'm just going to copy the code across
and just briefly explain what's
happening
you can obviously go ahead and create
any custom controls you want and explore
the functionality there
for us we're going to keep that for a
separate video so
what we're going to do is follow the
walkthrough and
when you click on an item it's going to
have a star rating out of five
so we're going to go ahead and just
simply add that and get it to work
so the first thing we need to do in our
controller
is create a product
rating.js file which is going to handle
all of our logic
and we're going to
throw in all of the custom code there's
quite a lot of it
um and we're just going to save so
obviously
there's quite a lot going on here but
effectively we're just
using the different controls in sap
and sort of gluing them together um
into sort of a a sort of
star rating setup kind of thing
and so once we've got this
file here you can go through it but
we're just going to move on from here
we're going to go ahead and save it
and now we need to move on to our detail
view and we're going to bring in this
new control
and to do that we call the xmlns
and we give it an alias of wt
and we call it sap dot ui
dot demo dot walk through
dot control
and we can save that
and all we do is we pull in the
product rating um
control here
and we slot it in just at the end of our
page
and we can just format that correctly so
we've got a product rating with its id
some class attributes and obviously the
change the on rating change event so
what happens when you change your rating
etc
and now we are going to create
the controller or rather we're going to
edit the controller for the detail page
and we're going to edit the following
we need to bring in the message
toast
module over here
and we need to include that
over here
and now that we have this detail
we need to push across so
what's going to happen is the rating is
going to reset in this case
so we need to make sure that we
reset that rating as we go back and
forth so
it'll make sense um once we're there
but we just need to add it
to this so we're calling this by id
the rating which is the rating control
and we just want to reset it so
when we um initialize our app and our
controller
it's just going to reset the ratings
because this is just a test
sort of test scenario and then
under the on nav back
call we're going to add the on rating
change
get rid of that and so all this is doing
is um it's just basically going to
show us it's going to show us a message
here um
and it's just going to run through the
logic of the custom control
and now we're going to add some bits and
pieces to our css
and all we're doing
is underneath here
and this is just some standard css which
we'll see
in a few seconds and just save that
and in the i18n properties we are going
to
add a few more things so the detail page
is just going to get the rating
confirmation
call here to the i18n file and we're
going to add the product rating details
underneath perfect
so let's have a look and see if it works
refresh
right so let's go ahead and click on one
and it looks like we've run into an
issue it's got the path here which is
fine so let's check the console
fail to load sample you to walk through
control r
i've put the j the um product rating js
in the wrong folder
so let's go ahead jump back to the code
ah here it is so what i was supposed to
do was
under web app i was supposed to add a
folder called control
and this was meant to sit here
that was the issue so if i refresh
there you go so we can go back click on
canned beans
and we can rate it fantastic there's a
little
pop-up there so again all of this
is handled in the product rating js
controller
i mean the product rating control
javascript file here so you'll you can
pretty much do anything you want if you
find the standard controls
are not good enough you can have a look
through this and see the logic
and see what happens um and you could
pretty much build anything you want if
you find the standard sap controls
are not really enough for what you're
trying to do in your project
right now in step 35 we're going to look
at the responsiveness of our app and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
use
a standard sap m table control
to turn or to make the app a little bit
more
responsive so that it can deal with
different screen sizes
and we're going to do that in the view
so
let's go back to our code and we need to
go to our invoice
list control uh invoice list view sorry
so let's just get rid of all this stuff
so underneath our
invoice list view
we are going to um
instead of using a list we are going to
use a table control which also comes
from the sap dot em library
and let's just close that off
and once we have that
we need to go ahead and add two sections
to it so we're still going to keep our
header toolbar and all of that plus
we've got all of our attributes for the
table
including our aggregation data
aggregation binding rather
so underneath the header toolbar
here we're going to add the columns
section
and here we're going to specify each
individual column that we wanted to
appear so
[Music]
let's open up that control there
and underneath columns we have a column
binding so we're going to have a few of
these column bindings
and under here we are going to have a
few attributes
so the first one is horizontal align
equals end then we're going to have
minimum
screen width so we're specifying the
absolute minimum screen width
that this control can be viewed in
and that's going to be small
and the demand poppin
is going to be set to true so we'll
allow that
width is going to be set
at 4 e m
so these are just sort of specifics that
we're adding but you can obviously
change these to see what happens
and we can go ahead and close that off
and we just need to close off our column
section and now we are going to
specify a text control
and the text attribute for that
is going to be from our i18n file
and we're going to set that as column
quantity
and so we can go ahead and add that in
to our file for now so let's actually
just get that started
so this will actually go under the
invoice
list here and this will be called
quantity
brilliant so now that we have this text
control
in here we can move on to the
uh the next one so
again specifying
column closing that off
oops column
and um we're not going to
worry about any attributes in this
column we're just simply going to call
our text we're going to simply add our
text control again
with the text attribute
i 18n oops i
18n and this is going to be
column name so
oops let's just make sure we close that
off
and we can take that pop it into
our i18n name
perfect no
there we are then
we are going to add the column status so
again opening up a new column
and here we are going to specify the
minimum screen width as well
and screen width
equals small
and demand poppin
equals true
so again this demand poppin is just
saying that if the column if it's too
small for the column to appear
it's going to allow you to basically
choose to see it if you want to
so that's obviously set to true you can
also set that in the table control
as well to apply to all columns but
we're going to do it in
for each specific column
and we're just going to close that off
oops
and we're going to add our text control
text attribute and
again i 18n
and this is going to be column status
and we'll copy that that here
equals status
make sure we save as we go along
and just close all our text control
there
now we're going to move on to the
supplier column
and again we are going to
set the minimum screen width
screen width
equals and we're going to set this to
tablet so the minimum screen with it
will
show on is up to tablet so on the phone
it won't
on a mobile device it won't um
and the demand pop-in
is going to be set to false so we're
going to remove that functionality
so we can go ahead and close that up
close up our column
and we can add our text control
with the text attribute calling
i 18n and
column supplier
copying that to i18n properties and
setting that to supplier oops
and let's go ahead and close that
and now we're going to add the final
price
uh final column rather which is price
column
and um we're just going to etch a line
or horizontal align to the
end so it's going to sit on the right
oops column
and close that off
and all we're going to do is add the
final text control
with the text attribute from our i18n
file
[Music]
18n and
column
price i just need to change that as well
because i haven't spelt it correctly
um so that's going to be column supplier
and that's going to equal price
perfect right
so now we have all of our columns set
with all their different attributes
depending on screen size
and whether or not we can actually open
the column itself with the pop-in
and everything's referenced in our i18n
file now
we need to sort out our items and to do
that
we need to call something
that is known as the column list item
column list item
so we can actually basically get rid of
most of this um
and then let's just
comment it out for now so we can refer
back to it if we need to
so under the column list item
we're just putting in some attributes
and the first one is it's going to be
navigation so that we can
click on it and we're going to do press
and obviously that's the on press event
just like we've used before and we're
going to close that off
no close it all far here
and uh now that we've got that we
should close it off underneath
perfect and
once we're in here we can then call
the um
the control called cells
we're going to specify what we see
within the cells themselves
close that off lovely
so now we're going to add all of the
bits and pieces that we had before so
the first thing is
we're going to add the an object number
uh we've got to open that up properly
though
and the object number is set with
our i18n file
and we're going to call the invoice
quantity notice we're doing this in the
order of the columns so the first one is
the quantity
and we're setting this as emphasized
infer sized
as false
right now we're going to do the next
column but the actual cells
and this is going to be an object
identify
with the title attribute
of um
apologies this is not the i18n this is
now from our model
uh please ignore that that previous part
this is actually from
the model itself and
we're calling it like that so from the
invoice model
pull the quantity field it's very
important
so now again we're going to call the
invoice
product name
and we can close that off there
and now we're going to open up a text
control with the text attribute
and under here we're going to put a
path to our invoice status and we're
going to add our formatter
just like we did before so path
and that comes from the invoice
model and status
and pulling in the
whoops formatter
and our formatter is located at
at this part or this under this part of
the folder structure
and we're calling the method status
text just like we did before
and now that we have that text control
we can go ahead and close that off
and now we want the ship and name for
the next column
another text control text attribute
and pulling it again from the model
invoice model
shipper shipper name
close that off and now we are going to
pull in the
extended price so
object number and again these are all
just different controls
which you can read the documentation on
that you can use within the table itself
object number and we put in the
number
and now we can specify the
parts
and in here we're going to reference the
path
to the uh so now we're bringing in the
extended price but we're also bringing
in
the currency as well so that we can um
apply the formatting to that
so invoice
extended price
and now that we have that we can add
the path to
invoice i'll just close that off invoice
and currency
uh oh sorry uh so again i'm not pulling
the
currency from the um
the invoice model in our controller
for the invoice list we created a
model there which is where we got our
currency from
so that comes from our view
the view is the name of the model that
we created
and we're pulling in the currency
brilliant
so that's all there
and now we're going to type it with our
sap
data type sap dot ui dot
model dot type dot
currency
and we're going to include our format
options
so we've done this all before we're just
redoing it for this particular table
control
and show measure is set to
false so
again we're running it all through
this section so just like we did before
and now that we have that object number
here
that's all sitting fine um
now once we move past the
show measure we can close off
the format options
and then
we can go ahead and jump down to here
where we'll add our unit
and that will be
from our view model that we created in
our controller
and adding in our currency
and the state just like we did before
is going to be um an expression bar
and it's going to be determined using
expression binding
so that runs there and we use the dollar
symbol
to call the extended price from our
invoice
to be compared extended price
and we're saying if it is greater than
50
evaluate if true
give it an error or make it red
effectively
and make it green with the success
s-u-c-c-e-s-s perfect
and we can close that off so
you'll remember all of this complex
logic was here an
object list item and we no longer need
that
because we're now handling all of it in
our table
so table underneath the items we have a
column list item in our cells
all of our cells are here in the order
that we placed
our columns simple as that
and save the r18n properties so
now let's see if it worked
refresh
hmm so it still looks like we've got an
issue
let's have a look at the console
right it seems to be an xml issue
so we put out a lot of xml so there it
probably is
something wrong ah okay
so it looks like this isn't closed off
ah we haven't closed off our text
control
brilliant so let's double check our app
again
fantastic it's all working here
but something's wrong with our supplier
why is that not coming through so let's
go ahead and check the code again
and let's find um the
shipper and see
text invoice spelling mistake again
supposed to be invoice shipper name so
let's save that
and have a look again
there you are fantastic so now you can
see
everything's in a nice little neat table
and if you were to test this on a tablet
or mobile device
you can see how things would change so
if we had to press f12 and click on this
toggle device toolbar and refresh
you can see how it changes it
and it the having it in this table
control allows it to still be
viewed but we only have certain columns
available depending
on the screen size so we can go ahead
and close that
and there you are
now in this section step 36
we're going to go through device
adaption so we're going to adapt the ui
based on the device that you have so in
this example we're going to make the
panel
collapsible and we're also going to
hide the button on certain devices
the the hello world button
so let's go ahead and dive straight
in the first thing we need to do
in our code is
find the hello panel view no
that's uh here we are
hello panel view and in here
we need to find our panel section
and let's just tidy this up
and what we're going to do is we're
going to set
two properties first of all we're going
to set
expand expandable
and that we're going to sit based on our
device
model which we're going to create
shortly
and that's going to be
system phone so the device model
is going to house this variable here and
of this field here rather and that's
going to determine whether or not this
is actually expandable
and we're going to say expanded
expand
is going to equal um
uh so we uh probably pulling in the
expression binding here again
and we're just saying that it's not the
expanded
is going to not equal whatever the value
is
um from the device model so
um we now call dollar and we call
device and
whoops system slash phone
so when we do this model it'll obviously
make more sense
so we've now set that up and now for the
button
we want to say only visible
on desktop so all we do for that in the
button is to add another class
sap ui visible
oops i've got to put it in quotes
visible only
only on desktop
so we've got that class as well super
so let's now dive into our component
where we're going to create our
device model um
component now that we're in component
we need to add the device model here and
bring in the modules so
that is going to come from sap slash ui
device and we need to bring in the
device model here
and let's go ahead and set the device
model
over here so
set device
model and we're going to create a
variable for
the device model a device model
and it's going to be equals new json
model device which we've now pulled in
and the oh device model
uh we're going to obviously we need to
set the binding
it only needs to be one way bound which
is fine set default
set default binding
and that's going to be set as one
way
and then this dot set model
o device model and we'll give it an
alias of device
perfect so we've just now again set the
model
uh to our context
and now we need to look at the
save that first now we need to jump into
our detail view
so in our detail view here
we need to find our object header
and within the object header we are
going to specify
the responsive
attribute and set that to true
and we want full screen
optimized
equals true
and now we are going to move a few
things around
and we are going to set the
number um
like this and we're going to set
the paths so similar to how we did this
in
the overview page
we're gonna set the path
um and we're going to link that to our
invoice
model extended
extended price
and we want to pull in our currency just
like we did before
so we add in
a path and
from the same view model
we pull in
the currency
and now that we have that we add the
type and it's obviously a
um a currency type so sap
ui dot model
dot type dot currency
and adding an alpha oops format
options
we call show measure and set it to false
and now that we have that we want to add
the number unit
and we set that again to the currency
from our view model
perfect so now that we have that
we've got our number number unit intro
and title
now we are going to add some
attributes so
let's just open up our object header
here first
we'll close it rather object
header now here we're going to add a
new control called attributes
and we're going to close that off
and under here we're going to add some
object attributes
and the first one is object
attribute and that's going to have a
title of
whoops put that in quotes
of i 18 in
quantity
title and
whoops quantity title
so let's just take that
and add it to our i18n properties
equals one two oops
q-u-a-n-t rty
and back here we are going to say
oh sorry that's the title and then this
is the text attribute
which is going to be from our invoice
model the quantity
itself quantity
and we can um close that
off and we just take this
and close it off under here
perfect and now
we're going to add one more object
attribute
and give that a title
for the date so i18
in i18n
date title
and let's go put that in our i18n file
set that to date save
uh then we're going to add the text
attribute
which is going to be a formatted shipped
shipped date and we're going to format
it just like we did
for our number here so that's going to
look
like this specify the
path and it comes from
invoice
shift date
and then we're going to specify the data
type which is going to be
date
zap dot ui dot model
and we're going to add some formatting
options
format options format options
and under here we're going to say style
long
and the source is going to contain the
pattern we want
pat term and the pattern is going to be
yoyo whoops
dash month month dash
date time
hour hour and seconds
perfect so
[Music]
that's fine close that off save
so that is our attributes done so we've
now added a bit more detail
to our detail page now
we need to jump into our detail
controller
and here detail controller and now we
need to add the model
just like we did for the other
controller for the
for the view where we add this view
model with
the euro currency in it
so we're going to now add the module
first
sap slash ui model
slash jason
slash jason model
and we're going to put that there jason
model
and now on the init function all we're
going to do
is create the model so var
view will create a variable first for
the
overview model and that's going to equal
a new
json model
and we're going to set an attribute to
currency
as euro
now that we have that we're going to set
the model to the view so this dot
get view dot set
model oh
view model with an alias of view
so we can pull that in and we can go
ahead and save that
and we've added in our
18n properties so
this will actually be order date so we
can save that
so let's go and see if it works
go ahead and refresh
right it seems we've run into an issue
which is fine let's see
fail to load component for container
reason o device model set default
binding
r this is mean to be set default binding
model
my apologies so if we go back to the
code
we need to jump into our component and
where it says oh device model that's it
default binding needs to be
mode it's default binding mode which is
one way
so let's save refresh
right it seems we've run into another
issue so let's check the console again
it is an xml issue in the hello panel
so let's go and take a look at that
uh the panel header text expanded
there should probably be a space there
um icon
text press oops press claw
ah apologies uh
these need to be in the same quotation
marks
and i think that should fix that
let's just save
refresh
and there we are so uh now that we've
got our panel and everything
let's take a look um
and refresh it so now
when you go into your mobile mode or
mobile device
mode you can see this panel
is here and what we've done is we've now
controlled
or we've decided what the controls look
like and can do
on different screen sizes so if we had
to
get out of the console and refresh
the panel goes back to normal
so now in step 37 we're going to look at
content density
and we're going to adjust the content
density based on the user's device
which means you could have a mobile
device with touch enabled so you'd want
your
buttons and things to be a bit bigger
for your items and your table to be a
bit bigger
perhaps you want them to be a bit
smaller and more compact
on a larger screen like a laptop so you
can get more information in
so we're going to go ahead and add that
functionality in
so let's jump into the code and
let's get our component open
and in here we're going to find our
init function and just after it
we are going to call get content
density class
and we're going to run a function of
that
where we are going to do the following
we're going to say if
this dot underscore
is cont whoops s
content density class so if a content
density class doesn't exist
we need to add it so we're going to say
if
the device dot
oops support
touch so if the oops if the
device doesn't support touch
we need to set the
the density class to compact so
this dot underscore s
constant content density class
let's set that there content density
class
is going to equal sap ui
size compact
else
this dot underscore
is content density
class is going to equal cosy sap
um size
cozy
and um once we've run through
that we are going to go ahead
and return
this dot underscore
um content density class oh sorry
return
and that is that if
that opens there perfect so
that's fine so we're just determining
whether or not we need to return the
compact or cozy density class
based on our logic here um
so now that we have that let's run to
our app
controller
and in our app controller we're going to
add the on init
event
function and
on uh let's just add our comma and
within this function we are going to say
this
dot get view dot
add style class
and we're going to reference our
component
this dot get owner component
and we're going to get the content
density class so get
content density
class and
that's fine so um
we're just we're just literally going to
add the style class
based on the um what's happening in that
logic
in our component here so we're calling
this
now let's go ahead and find our hello
dialog dot js
and in here we are going to add
the sync style class module
sap slash ui slash call
slash sync style
class
and we're going to bring that in
and now when we
when basically when we're loading our
fragment
all we're going to do is we're going to
send through the settings
so we're going to forward the compact
or cozy style into the dialog
so we call sync style class
and we pass in our overview controller
get controller
and get owner
component component
and we are going to get
content density class
and we are going to set the view
and the dialogue
oh dialogue
and let's just make sure i've opened
this up ah
there we are it's the problem so sync
style class
getting the content density class for
the view and the dialog
we can save that now
we need to jump back into our manifest
and we're looking for the
sap ui5 section
and now we want to find the content
densities
over here and we're now going to turn
them on have them available
in the manifest so
let's go ahead and see if it's now
shrunk
in desktop mode these items so these
should appear
a little bit thinner
and there you go so it might be hard to
see but effectively these
because we're now in the state and we're
not on our mobile device
it's shrunk these a little bit and so
the content density has been changed
based on the device
so now the final section uh or step
step 38 is going to be accessibility
and all we're going to do is we're going
to
add some aria attributes
to and that's accessible rich internet
applications that's what that stands for
and all they are are there a set of
attributes to make things
as readable as possible for people that
battle to use computers
people who might be visually impaired um
we're gonna try and make the app as
readable for them as possible
so let's go ahead and
jump straight in
and we're going to first jump into the
overview dot xml
and once we're in here we're going to
add a landmark info control
and what we're going to do is underneath
the page
we need to add land
info and we
are just going to go ahead and close
that
off
and once we've done that um
we're going to add something called a
page accessible landmark info
control so page
access
accessible landmark
info control oh and uh let's just
close that off
from here we're going to just add some
attributes
and so we've got root roll
and that's set as region
root label
it's going to be set as
i oops i 18 n
hi 18n and it's going to be the
overview whoops oh
overview root
label
and let's just go ahead and
add that to our
i18n file
over here so
[Music]
the view page
over new page and the root
label is going to be overview
page um and we're also going to have
a overview
header label oops
and that's going to be header
and we're also going to have an over
overview content label
to label our content and
this is just going to be
this is going to be header
and this is just going to be page
content
so these are just the labels we're going
to have for the different sections which
you'll see now when we run the page
and we've got a rate whoops
rating title
for rate the product
perfect so we've specified all of those
um so we've got um our root label here
and we are going to then specify the
content
role
which is going to be on the main
and we've got the content label
specified from our i18n file as the
overview overview
content label
and the header role
is going to be set to a banner which
will make sense when we actually
whoops refresh the app and the
header label will be set as
again i 18n
overview overview
uh header label
so we've got all of our different labels
here which is perfect
root label head label content label
brilliant
so you save that now we need to jump in
to our invoice list view
and in here we need to find
we're going to add a panel at the top
and specify a few bits and pieces
so we need to open up
a panel here
and we've got our accessible
roll set to region
and we can close that off so let's keep
let's close off our panel here
and now we need to add in a header
toolbar
header
toolbar and we just
want to close that off as we go so we
don't forget about it
and underneath our header toolbar we
want a toolbar
also go ahead and close that
off lovely
and now we are going to add a title
control
with the text attribute
from our eye 18 in
file and it's the in
invoice list
oops it needs to be in quotes
that's going to be the invoice list
title which we've already got
close that off then we're going to add
in our toolbar spacer to separate things
out
toolbar spacer
and now we are going to call a search
field
i mean it's just
so we now had a search field
with a width
of 50
and when we search we're going to run it
on filter invoices
that's the event on
filter invoices
lovely and um
arya
aria labeled by
a search field label search
field label so now we're adding in these
different
labels which you'll see appear shortly
labeled by oh sorry
aria described by
search field description
description
and we're just going to add a
placeholder
and that's going to come from the i18n
search field
placeholder and we have that
the i18n search field placeholder
uh search field placeholder
no so where is it let's go ahead and
just add it
so so that's all good
and now we just close this
off and everything is fine so now we've
got our new panel
holding our table and hit a toolbar
and now we've got our label and our
description here ready to go
so now we
need to jump into the hello panel view
and under here we are going to add
oops
oh come on
we're going to add the accessible
roll we're going to add the accessible
roll
region brilliant so that's going to be
included as well
and so let's go ahead
and see if it works
all right it looks like we have a small
issue let's f12 into the console
and it looks like something's
wrong in the
uh where is it in the overview view so
the xml
so let's close this and have a look in
our overview
and see everything's fine fine fine
okay this is white which means i haven't
closed this off
let's see if that worked
so now when we refresh the page
um you'll see uh
once we so we can press um alt shift l
um
obviously you need to install um
something like the landmarks control
extension in the google chrome store
where you can find that
that will be linked in the walkthrough
itself
but i have it installed already so if i
press something like alt shift
l
you can see i have all my different
sections
laid out here and
that's pretty much it so you can add
these wherever you need them
and it helps for people who are for
example visually impaired to
sort of navigate around and and um
yeah better use your app
all right so that wraps up this full ui5
course
um covering the basics of building a ui5
application
um i hope it's helped you at some point
and well done if you managed to make it
through from
step one all the way through to the end
as always if you need access to any of
the steps or
code bits you can find them on
the github repository which will be
linked down in the description
plus again you can always refer back to
the sap documentation and the sap
walkthrough
which will have pretty much everything
you need um
on top of what i've covered here um if
you have any questions please feel free
to comment down below
and i'll help where i can but otherwise
don't forget if you liked the video
please hit that like and subscribe
button
and as always thanks for watching